So, ja ich muss gerade nochmal neu starten, exellent, ah, yes, so, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
so, so Leute, ich gebe nextcloud noch eine Chance, ich guck mir heute version 19 an
und wenn da immer noch alles dabei ist, was mir auf den Keks geht und sich nichts geändert hat, dann kommt was anderes bei mir hin.
Letzte Chance für nextcloud heute. Oh, Toxy sieben Monate, ajajaja, big brain subscription, der plops rusher auch, noch mehr. Moment, das ist ja fast schon.
Massive chat IQ. Ok, ich glaube die Musik muss ich ein bisschen leiser machen.
So, exellent. Was soll das für ein mega hässlicher Yoshi.
Na gut, ähm, gleich kommt der Scam train, ja der kann ruhig kommen.
Äh, wieso, achso, äh, nee eigentlich gar nichts, weder das eine noch das andere, ich hab grad, äh, was gefuttert und vielleicht habe ich so lange nichts gesagt.
Keine Ahnung. Ach, hast recht, irgendwie bin ich ein bisschen, ah, bei warmen Tee trinken.
Ah, yes, nee kein Kreiselgrind. Ich kann mal was gucken. Euskete ist drin.
Ja, passt, ok. Big brain inception, ja. Also, wo fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an?
Äh, ich hab schon seit Jahren eine Nextcloud Installation bei mir laufen, seit das ganze noch Oncloud hieß, ich mach mal kurz hier das, oder Scam train ist am Start, Separo, Dankeschön für den Sub, oder für den verschenkten Sub, Sys 0 hat eingekriegt.
Der Scam train ist am Start, Leute. Huge Chebatrain.
Also, wie gesagt, ich hab den Kram schon laufen seit es noch Oncloud war.
Die, die, die setzen auf Verschreiber, die setzen auf Verschreiber. Oh, du Scheiße. Da weiß man jetzt schon, dass man nicht drauf gehen muss in den Scam-Shop.
Also, so gut optimisiert haben sie nicht, weil sonst würden sie hier auftauchen. Paar Schulen nach Minuten, ja, dann mach das mal. C-File gibt es doch als Alternative, ja, ich bin auch am gucken.
Wahrscheinlich wird es das hier werden, wenn Nextcloud immer noch mir nicht gefällt. Warum nicht Magenta-Cloud?
Haben wir nicht genug Magenta-DNA für? Ja, also, wie gesagt, wo wollte ich denn jetzt anfangen? Wie gesagt, ich hab schon eine Nextcloud-Installation laufen, da hieß das ganze noch Oncloud, und ich weiß gar nicht, was ist eigentlich mit Oncloud mittlerweile? Gibt es sie noch, oder?
Da tut sich, glaube ich, nicht allzu viel. Die haben vor einem Jahr oder so mal ein neues Webinterface angekündigt, wo sich nicht allzu viel getan hat. Der Musikmix nervt mich.
Machen wir was anderes. Top 300 Nintendo Songs of All Time. Exzellent. Das machen wir jetzt. Ja, leg los. Was ist mit dem YouTube-Video los? Ich kann nicht auf die Leiste klicken.
Du, du, du.
Mario Odyssey Song. Okay, also. Gut, also wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Ja, und mir ging schon bei Oncloud ein paar Sachen auf den Keks.
Zum Beispiel, dass es relativ inkonsistent im Webinterface war. Manche Bilder konntest du öffnen, manche Bilder konntest du nicht öffnen, manche Texte konntest du bearbeiten, manche Texte konntest du nicht bearbeiten.
Obwohl es alles der gleiche Button war, hat er manchmal die Sachen geöffnet, manchmal runtergeladen. Eine Suche, da hat in Oncloud noch keiner dran gedacht.
Und generell, dass Oncloud damals schon relativ viele Apps hatte, allerdings die ganzen Apps zum größten Teil irgendwie Low-Quality waren.
Also sprich, da gab es dann eine Notizen-App, die man nicht durchsuchen kann. Ich meine, wozu braucht man eine Notiz-App, wenn man sie nicht durchsuchen kann?
Das hat komplett beknackt. Ich meine, dann schreibst du über zwei Notizen und sagst, ah Mist, ich hab mir das vor einem Jahr mal aufgeschrieben und kann es nicht suchen. Ah, das ist ja...
Cacquade. So, und das hat sich ein bisschen gebessert bei Nextcloud. Allerdings haut Nextcloud massig Zeugs raus, wo ich mir denke, okay, für meinen persönlichen Bedarf daheim ist es jetzt nicht so geil.
Du hast hier so Dinge drinne, wie... Mal gucken, ob die das jetzt anzeigen. Du hast quasi diese Chat- und Videokonferenz-Software haben die jetzt drinne. Dann haben sie jetzt noch komische Kanban-Boards drinne.
Und warte mal, hier, genau, Nextcloud Deck haben sie jetzt noch. Das sind alles so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, okay, nice to have, aber so wirklich brauche, tue ich es zumindest daheim nicht.
Das heißt nicht, dass es schlecht wäre, dass es das hat, aber... Ich meine, ich brauche kein Kanban-Board daheim. Hat jemand von euch ernsthaft mal ein Kanban-Board daheim bei irgendwelchen privaten Projekten?
Okay, ich weiß, wenn ich das so frage, gibt es jetzt den ersten, der sagt, ja, natürlich Max, smiley face. Aber ernsthaft, hat jemand von euch schon mal zuhause bei irgendeinem privaten Projekt und sei es auch, muss ja gar nicht softwareentwicklungmäßig sein, mal ein Kanban-Board verwendet? Also ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Das ist was, was die Stonks-Leute im Businessbereich geil finden, aber daheim machst du sowas eigentlich recht wenig.
Hast du kein 78 Zoll Whiteboard-Buddy im Zimmer? Ich habe einen Surface Hub bei mir im Zimmer. Hier im Arbeitszimmer. Die ganze Wand ist Surface Hub.
Das ist der V-Shop? Das ist der V-Shop!
Der V-Shop!
Du, du, du! Du, du, du! V-Shop Musik! V-Shop Musik ist die beste!
Du, du, du, du, du, du!
Ich weiß auch nicht warum ich die V-Shop Musik kenne, ich glaube ich hab nicht eine
Sache im V-Shop gekauft, weil ich meine Wii auch nicht mit Originalspielen gefüttert
hab, aber das kann ich jetzt nicht vertiefen, weil das ist sicherlich, auch wenn es schon
längst verjährt und abgelaufen ist, Monkathos auf Twitch da Näheres zu erzählen.
Aber das war zumindest ganz nice, kann ich mich auch dran erinnern, dass man, weil Wii
Spiele, gerade bei der Wii war das Laufwerk so übelst lahm auch und ich hab dann irgendwann
einfach eine Festplatte dran gemacht und halt mit dem passenden Hack konnte man dann
die Spiele von der Festplatte laden und das geilste, ich mein jetzt zu laut war die Musik,
ja und das geilste, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das mal gemacht habt, ne Custom, es war keine
Customfirme auf die Wii muss man sagen, das war ein, das war ein Patch, der halt Speicherzugriff
gebraucht hat, das war keine komplette Customfirme, aber ist das Streamlogtool an, ne, aber ich
kann gleich hochscrollen wenn ich was übersehen hab, Streamlogtool muss ich noch anmachen,
so zumindest war das, wenn man die Wii, ich nenne es mal Flaschen wollte, ich weiß das
nicht wirklich Flaschen war, war total abgedreht, du musstest eine manipulierte SD Karte mit
einem Twilight Princess, warte mal war das Twilight Princess auf der Wii, ja ja das war
Twilight Princess, du musstest einen manipulierten Twilight Princess Spielstand nehmen, auf
die SD Karte machen und dann von der SD Karte den Spielstand laden und der Spielstand war
so manipuliert, dass man konnte den Twilight Princess den Namen vom Pferd, konnte man
bestimmen wie das hieß, es gab auch, Letterbomb war später, Letterbomb war später, als erstes
war, ich weiß nicht wie dieser komische Twilight Hack noch hieß, ich glaub der hieß einfach
Twilight Hack, ich weiß es nicht mehr, zumindest musstest du dann rückwärts laufen und dann
hat der NPC den Namen vom Pferd ausgesprochen und dadurch, dass der Name vom Pferd im Speicherstand
manipuliert war, ist und die das nicht abgefragt haben im Twilight Princess, ist das quasi
übergelaufen und zufälligerweise genau auf dem Speicherbereich vom USB irgendwie rauskommt,
ganz ab, ganz ab, ultra abgedrehtes Zeug ja und zumindest konnte man, man hat damals
eine Twilight Princess Kopie gebraucht, einen manipulierten Spielstand und dann konnte man
die Custom Software laden und konnte dann von der USB Festplatte Zeug laden und ich weiß
noch, es hat nur am unteren USB Anschluss funktioniert, nicht am oberen, wahrscheinlich
weil der Speicherbereich da nicht gepasst hat, also das war Massive, Moment, mit meiner
eigenen Emotion, Massive, ja, war das ganze, ich bin recht neu auf Twitch, was bedeutet
Monka oder Toss, wo kommt das her, immer diese Internet Sprache, na Toss sind die Terms of
Service, das ist, Toss sagst du immer, wenn irgendwas nicht, was wahrscheinlich doch den
Terms of Service entspricht, aber irgendwas, was erstmal so wirkt, als würde es nicht
den Terms of Service entsprechen, sagst du, zum Beispiel, wenn dir irgendwie einer einen
Pornhub Link schickt und du sagst, das kann ich jetzt nicht anklicken, das ist Monka Toss,
so und Monka ist im Prinzip alle möglichen Emotes, die hier, ursprünglich war das hier,
die irgendeine Abwandlung von dem Frosch sind, so und dementsprechend ist Monka Toss das
hier, jetzt weißt du Bescheid, ja, so und irgendwas hat hier oben einer vorhin noch
gefragt, das hab ich übersehen, es gibt auch Monka DB, das sieht dann so aus, Leute, ich
hab hier gestern irgendwie 10 Stunden oder so gestreamt, keine Ahnung, viel zu lang, ne,
ich merke das voll im Hals, dass ich irgendwie ein bisschen heiser bin jetzt seit gestern,
viel zu lang bin ich das gar nicht gewohnt, äh, oh der Skillkiller hat gefragt, kannst
du mal erklären, wie Mails mit Kalendersync geht, wenn ich auf Arbeit einen Termin erstelle
und einen extern als Teilnehmer einträge, bekommt er ja eine Mail und das ist in seinem
Kalender, wie geht das, äh, ich hab ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ich denke mal, das ist
irgendein Outlook Feature, ha, Monka Corona gibt es auch noch, ja, aber ich hab die animierte
Version, die ist besser, ich vermute mal, das ist irgendein Outlook Feature, es gibt
auch irgendwas, da kannst du Termine verschicken und Thunderbird versteht es auch, aber ich
hab keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert, hab ich nicht gemacht, so, ich muss jetzt erstmal
meine vm hier starten, Active Sync ist das von Outlook, genau, das Microsoft Ding, ja
ein weiterer Punkt, der mich ja Nextcloud auch noch genervt hat, neben, oder auch an
owncloud damals schon, neben der ganzen Geschichte, dass es halt, dass es zwar viele Apps gab,
aber halt einige Sachen total Low-Quality waren, dass, äh, die ganze CalDAF Geschichte, also
CalDAF ist ja ein Protokoll zum Kalendersynken, dass die irgendwie nicht so verbreitet ist,
wie sie sein sollte, weil CalDAF ist ein offener Standard zum Synken von, also gibt es drei
Varianten, es gibt WebDAF, CalDAF, CardDAF, CalDAF ist für Kalender, CardDAF ist für
Kontakte, WebDAF ist für File Access, so, ähm, und im Prinzip ist WebDAF das untentrohliche,
aber ist, ist verboscht, so, und, das ist ein offener Standard, den gibt es schon richtig
lang, aber, das hat sich nie so durchgesetzt, dass man sagen könnte, äh, es ist, es ist
so verbreitet, dass du es bedenkenlos nutzen kannst, also, du kannst, man konnte es lange
Zeit unter iOS und Mac ziemlich gut verwenden, die hatten eine ziemlich gute CalDAF Unterstützung,
zum Beispiel die Standard-iOS-Tasks, die Standard-iOS-Nodes, die Standard-iOS-Kalender, Standard-iOS-Kontakte,
alles CalDAF, ähm, also wunderbar, Android wurde schon ein bisschen schwieriger, die
faultmäßig nicht, weil Google natürlich in eigenen Shit da, oder die Leute bringen
wollte, was, was, was auch sonst, ähm, allerdings ganz gut mit Addons, unter Windows sieht es
komplett düster aus, da gibt es gar nichts, es gibt nur diese, es gibt die Möglichkeit,
also wenn ihr, warte mal, Kalen, Kalender, ok, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man hier überhaupt
was edit, zumindest, genau, es gibt einen Trick, es gibt einen Trick, wenn man iCloud
auswählt, die haben eine ganze Weile CalDAF verwendet, kann man es dann umbiegen auf seinen
eigenen Nextcloud-Server, ist aber Shit, und es gibt keine To-Do-App unter Windows, keine
Kontakte-App und keine Kalender-App, die einfach, auf einfache Art und Weise CalDAF unterstützen
würde. Schau mal, erste Hindernis, für die ganze CalDAF-Geschichte, wenn das mit am weitesten
verbreiteten Desktop-Betriebssystem keine Out-of-Box-Integration mitbringt, ist schon
mal ein bisschen doof. So, und, ähm, auf Linux siehts, ähm, auch nicht viel besser
aus, es gibt eigentlich bloß Thunderbird, übergreifen, die gibt es ja auch für alle
anderen Betriebssysteme, aber ansonsten, es gibt halbwegs viele Kalender-Apps, allerdings
so gut wie keine richtig guten To-Do und Kontakte-Geschichten. Also, es ist zwar ein Standard-Protokoll, sollte
eigentlich genau dafür richtig gut sein, verwendet werden, aber die Verwendung ist jetzt nicht
so der, der Wahnsinn, ja, deswegen ist es halt auch fraglich, ob es so geil ist, dass,
äh, Nextcloud das hat, weil, wenns schlecht unterstützt ist, ne. Ah ja. Und, genau, das
ist so eine Sache, die mich schon immer genervt hat, das ist kein Fehler von Nextcloud, weil
ich mein, was sollen sie machen, wenns nicht unterstützt wird, aber ok, dann, das ist ja
nicht, ne, da kann ja Nextcloud nichts machen oder nicht viel dafür letztendlich, ähm,
aber letztendlich für die Leute, die es benutzen wollen, ist ja dann schon ein bisschen doof.
Und, ähm, dann gab es ganz, ganz am Anfang, wo ich angefangen hab, OnCloud zu verwenden,
gab es noch die Probleme, dass der Client, der Desktop-Client, dass der oftmals übelsten
Schrott gesüngt hat. Das hat mir einmal alle Files gelöscht, weil der Client auf dem einen
Rechner nicht richtig verbunden war und, ähm, dann der Meinung war, oder ich vermute mal,
weil er nicht richtig verbunden war, kein Schimmer, äh, und dann der Meinung war, alle Dateien
wurden gelöscht und dann hat der, quasi, die Löschaktion in Nextcloud gesüngt und
Nextcloud hat gesehen, aha, alle Dateien sind weg und alle Dateien auf dem zweiten Client,
der die Dateien auch hatte, wurden die Dateien auch gelöscht, weil ich hab hier die Dateien
angeblich auf dem ersten Client gelöscht, obwohl ich das gar nicht gelöscht habe. Da
hat quasi die Löschvorgang gesüngt. Das haben wir so mittlerweile auf die Reihe gekriegt,
da hab ich dann auch so ein bisschen, äh, gepaust gemmt vor meinem Rechner, aber ich
hatte zum Glück ein Backup und die Dateien, die man im Nextcloud züngt liegen hat, ist
ja auch nicht so groß meistens. So, der Rusty ist am Start, drei Monate, exzellent. Wupp,
wupp, bin zwar gerade beim Lernen am Verzweifeln, aber ich muss hier endlich mal wieder vorbeischauen.
Exzellent, Subscription. Wo ist er denn lernen? Gibt's nicht den Caldav Connector von Nextcloud
zu ordnen? Ja, gibt es, es gibt mittlerweile ein paar, äh, Hilfsmittel, allerdings muss
ich sagen, ich bin absolut kein Outlook-Fan. Ich hasse fast jedes Office-Programm. Von
Visio über Word bis PowerPoint bis Outlook. Das einzige Office-Programm, was irgendwie
ein bisschen eine Daseinsberechtigung hat, ist Exzell. OneNote geht auch noch, OneNote
hab ich auch mal eine Weile verwendet. OneNote, tatsächlich, OneNote geht auch noch. Das
schlimmste, Leute, das schlimmste, das größte Scheiß-Office-Programm der Welt ist das hier.
Microsoft Project, Alter. Das ist so ein Müll. Das musste ich mal verwenden für meine Abschlussprüfung
oder um ein Gantt-Diagramm zu erstellen. Das hab ich glaube ich schon 50 mal erzählt.
Wenn ich weiß, was ein Gantt-Diagramm ist, das ist ein Gantt-Diagramm. So, mit Vorgänge,
die aufeinander folgen und sowas. Es war so scheiße in Microsoft Project zu machen. Exzell
ist auch sowas, was keine Daseinsberechtigung hat. Exzell ist auch absoluter Müll. So,
so endet es. Um jetzt mal wieder zu, kennst du Lad? Ja, ja, kennen, aber nicht verwenden.
Ich schreib mittlerweile so gut wie alles in irgendeiner Markdown-Plain-Text-Variante,
es sei denn man braucht ein bisschen Formatierungsgeschichten. So, zumindest, es ist schon eine Weile her,
dass ich mir die letzte Next-Cloud-Version im Detail angeguckt hab. Ich hoffe ja, dass
mittlerweile die Suche funktioniert. Das ist eigentlich das Einzige, wo ich mir wünschen
würde, also was mich dazu bringen könnte, zu sagen, ja, okay, ich geb der ganze Sache
nochmal ne Chance, weil ansonsten hat das Ding zwar vieles an Featuren zugelegt, aber
halt nix, was ich gebrauchen kann. Das ist keine Schuld wirklich von dem Projekt, die
haben halt ihren Fokus ein bisschen anders ausgerichtet, aber ich brauch weder ein Kanban-Board,
noch brauch ich ne Chat- und Videokonferenz-App und was auch immer. Wir gucken uns mal an,
was in den, also ich hab noch, ich glaub, ich hab Next-Cloud 16 oder 17 oder so im Einsatz
bei mir grad noch. So, wir gucken mal, was in den letzten Versionen, wir gucken mal,
was die Highlights der letzten Version waren, bevor wir uns das Ganze angucken. Next-Cloud,
also das Ganze heißt jetzt, by the way, Next-Cloud Hub 19. Warum? Das heißt, also auf der Seite
heißt es noch Next-Cloud, offiziell heißt es Next-Cloud Hub. Versteh nicht. Na gut,
was kann sie meinen. Die machen jetzt alle auf Corona und Collaboration. Ja, das haben
wir uns ja auch mal angeguckt in allen der letzten Versionen, da gab es ja so nen Online-Office,
was angeblich konkurrieren sollte mit Office 365. Das war ja so grausam und hat nicht richtig
funktioniert. Das als Konkurrenz zur Office 365 zu sehen, war lachhaft. Aber gut, man
muss den Ding, man muss der ganze Sache natürlich zugute halten. Das ist das Hauptmesswort,
das ist kostenlos. Du kannst das verwenden, du musst es nicht verwenden. Nichtsdestotrotz
muss es sich, und das sag ich ja auch bei allen anderen kostenlosen Software, muss
es sich trotzdem der Konkurrenz bestehender, kommerzieller Software stellen, wenn das Software
ist, wo die Leute eben auch prinzipiell bereit sind, für Geld auszugeben. Also ich hätte
beispielsweise kein Problem mit, für eine ordentliche Lösung auch ein bisschen was
zu bezahlen. Und wenn es was gäbe, würde ich das sofort nehmen, auch wenn es ein bisschen
was kostet. Aber glücklicherweise gibt es auch sehr viele, na liebre Office, also hör
mal auf, aber zum Glück gibt es ja auch sehr viel richtig gute Open Source Software, die
jetzt eher im technischen Bereich zu finden ist, die absolut konkurrenzlos ist, wo es
auch nix Kommerzielles gibt, was da irgendwie rankommt. Guckt euch mal, sagen wir so etwas
wie Wireshark an. Wireshark ist eins der geilsten Sachen, die braucht man gefühlt jeden Tag
nicht, außer man ist Netzwerkmann, aber einmal die Woche mindestens, oder gibt es jede Menge,
oder guckt euch die ganzen aktuellen Webbrowser an und sowas. Also letztendlich, jeder benutzt
mittlerweile Open Source Software und am Strich wird ja auch das Internet so bis jetzt gar
nicht funktionieren. 80% der Server sind wahrscheinlich immer noch eine Mischung aus PHP und Apache,
oder so, keine Ahnung. Naja, ja und übrigens Nextcloud ist immer noch in PHP, hat irgendeiner
gefragt, gerade Nextcloud hier, der Tanzer hat gefragt, ist immer noch PHP, ja, ob das
so Eierjahr ist, weiß ich nicht. Aber Nextcloud wird auch weiter auf PHP bleiben, das ist
ja auch so ein Ding, wo ich immer Wert drauf lege, man sollte die Sachen nehmen, die sinnvoll
sind, und wenn Nextcloud einfach easy out of the box überall laufen will, ist PHP nicht
verkehrt, und wenn man ein riesen Projekt hat, was auf PHP basiert, man wird es im Leben
nicht alles neu programmieren, auf der anderen Programmiersprache. So, also was gibt es Neues
bei Nextcloud 19? Wieso, what's new Nextcloud 19, das ist erst rausgekommen vor ein paar
Tagen. Release, äußerst übersichtliche News-Seite, Nextcloud Beta ist out, und als nächstes
kommt eine Meldung, Beta 19, ok es gibt keine Release-Notes oder so, ne guck mal, what's
new, what's new, Nextcloud 19, ja, wat, ich lese doch jetzt kein Change-Log, ok guys,
warum, warum werden Leute time outed hier, keine Mod-Rechte für sinnlose Sachen missbrauchen
hier, ich hab nicht gesehen was er geschrieben hat, Calc Wait, gibt's denn hier nicht irgendeinen
what's new, latest updates, 19, die haben ja nun immer ne ordentliche News-Seite, wo steht
denn was neu ist in Version 19, ja, what's new, die Suche auf der Seite ist genau so gut
wie von Nextcloud, sie ist sogar powerbar, der Change-Log ist das Problem, das interessiert
mich ja nicht, Change-Log sind die einzelnen, also das ist sowas was mich als Entwickler
interessieren würde, aber ich will ja einfach nur wissen, ach steht's ja noch ein bisschen
genauer, ne, Release-Announcement, aha, das hätte man ja auch über die News-Seite finden
können, gucken wir mal, 3. Juni, wir gucken mal ob das in News drinnen stand, also das
ist bei older posts, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich das Release-Announcement, das hätte ich im
Leben nicht gefunden, was auch immer, also was ist neu in Nextcloud 19, können wir mal
gucken, kurz die Klimaanlage ausmachen, ganz viel Covid-Gedöns, how to get it, also Passportless,
Authentification, Make Security, gut, juckt mich jetzt daheim nicht, dann haben wir, das
ist alles noch ein Login gezählt, Replacing Coffee Chat and Focused Work, was, ach das
ist die Talk App, die juckt mich daheim auch nicht, ach man kann, haben die jetzt wirklich
eine Suche, quickly find what you need, da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das gut funktioniert,
dann gibt es jetzt ein Kanban Board, juckt mich jetzt auch nicht daheim, Gastzugang juckt
mich daheim auch nicht, toll, ok, so wie siehts mit Nextcloud 18 aus, was war da drinnen,
Release-Announcement, da bin ich auch nicht, so Nextcloud 18, Release-Announcement, Kanban,
ja, Poggo, ne Poggo, Pog, Pog, Poggo, wobei Pog, den, das Emote mag ich nicht, ich, ich
wäre damit nicht warm, also ich, ich, WeirdChamp ist für mich das einzig wahre WeirdPog Emote,
so was haben wir als nächstes hier, also das ist die Nextcloud 18 Version, was haben
sie Data hinzugefügt, Following Improvements, Workspaces, File Locking, Flow, also das klingt
schon mal, das klingt irgendwie ganz cool, ich weiß zwar nicht genau wofür man es verwenden
soll, aber, Only Office Build in Only Office Max, Collaboration, Editing, Microsoft, das
haben wir mal ausprobiert, das war, OkChamp war das, Gento Stream, oh je, das könnte man
wirklich mal aufschreiben, installieren wir mal ein Gento, so was haben wir hier, Fotos,
ok, Kalender 2.0, ja, das ist schon mal eine gute Änderung, die Kalender App hat mir nämlich
nicht gefallen, Cobalt Stream, das wird so pains Champ, das tut wirklich weh schon, Weihnachten
machen wir das, da muss ich mich vorher entspannt sein, dass ich Cobalt machen kann, so, da
gibt es neue Mail, App, ok, Talk, alles nicht so spannend, ok, wir probieren das jetzt einfach
mal aus, bevor wir jetzt noch Change Logs uns angucken, ja, QChat, QChat Git, QChat ich
lösche euch jetzt, und weg ist er, deleted, so, wo gibt es denn da ein Akt, ach, oha,
da hat er aber noch Zabbix an hier, warum haben wir denn so was an gehabt, Zabbix, warum
habe ich denn das offen, nein, die IP ist nicht leaked Leute, ja, die IP ist nicht leaked,
das war die externe IP von einem Digital Ocean Server, den ich gemietet habe, der ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mal, gar nicht ab, oder jemand anderes hat die IP jetzt, nee, der ist nicht, der
ist nicht mehr ab, Google, Keqwe, ja, ich weiß auch nicht warum, so, wir suchen uns
mal ein aktuelles, aktuelles, aktuellen Docker Container Next Cloud, ohja, ich kann, ich
kann Fehler freischreiben, wie man sieht, so, Next Cloud Docker Hub, 19, jawoll, nennen
wir so einen hier, die von denen, die Container von denen sind eigentlich immer ganz, ganz
brauchbar, warum sollte man, warum sollte ich Next Cloud nicht den ganz offiziell nehmen,
Autostart, Docker Run, 80, 80, Next Cloud, ja, aber wenn ich das mache, dann kann ich
ja kein Verzeichnis mounten, ne, das muss ich eher das da machen, what the fuck, was,
die Musik, Alter, what the fuck, was, du hast dich komplett aus der SSH Anmeldung ausgesperrt,
Alter, äh, wie hast du das denn geschafft, hä, das funktioniert doch im Leben, achso,
hier Next Cloud, ok, dann probieren wir das doch mal, haben wir hier, haben wir hier einen
Docker Ordner, mal, Next Cloud, so, und dann starten wir mal das Ding und gucken uns das
ganze mal an, und by the way, wir müssen den Port noch freigeben, sonst wird das ganze
nix, schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert, so, jetzt lädt er erstmal die ganzen Sporner
runter, gute Frage, nächste Frage, ok, also wo man sich relativ einfach bei SSH aussperren
kann, ist, wenn man sich den Server mietet, sagen wir mal bei Digital Ocean oder sonstwo,
und ähm, die root verwenden, sagen wir mal unter Ubuntu, was ja normalerweise gar nicht
so ist, du lockst dich ein per root, machst SSH, äh, machst Key kopieren, und dann, und
dann stellst du die SSH-Konfig um, dass root sich nicht mehr einloggen darf, und dann,
das ist mir auch schon passiert, aber das Schöne ist, dass man da natürlich ein Management-Interface
hat, wo man das wieder rückgängig machen kann, so, wo muss ich jetzt hin, port 8080,
localhost 8080, da sind wir, du hast die Konfig angepasst, hast du denn Zugriff auf deinen
Server, in irgendeiner anderen Art und Weise noch, also es gibt ja auch, also, ähm, ich
würde, ich würde es euch jetzt mal was zeigen, aber, ich kann es euch nicht zeigen, weil
ich hier nur mein Manjaro hab, mit, mit keinem Crop, also man kann, man kann, wenn man Zugriff
auf den Server hat und das root Passwort nicht kennt, und die Festplatte nicht verschlüsselt
ist, und man in den Bootmanager geht, dann kann man im Bootmanager eine Option, ein paar
Optionen angeben, dass man im Root-Filesystem landet, also physischer Zugriff auf den Server
ist ERIP, also du brauchst nicht das Root-Passwort nur auf den Server zuzugreifen, wenn du physischen
Zugriff hast, einziger Unterschied ist, äh, wenn die Festplatte verschlüsselt ist, dann
hast du gelitten, ja, ich hab das auch manuell installiert, ne, stimmt gar nicht, ich hab
das überhaupt nicht manuell installiert, ich hab das, ich hab das als Docker Compose-File
mit Traffic davor laufen, normalerweise, aber zum Testen ist das eigentlich ganz gut, äh,
Easykiller, das geht auch, was der Easykiller schreibt, das geht aber viel einfacher, der
Easykiller schreibt hier, ähm, ja, so, das hab ich ja gar nicht mitgeloggt, exellent,
er schreibt hier, äh, Live-Image-Booten-Platte einhängen und dann Shadow-Datei bearbeiten,
das geht auch, es geht aber viel einfacher, man geht einfach in Krab und gibt dort ein,
ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu ein Video gibt oder ein Bild, weil ich kann es euch auf manch
Ahnung nicht zeigen, man geht in Krab und gibt ein Init Bin Bash, zumindest unter Ubuntu
Debian geht das, unter Red Hat kann man eins angeben und, ah hier, Reset Lost Root-Passwort,
da steht es doch, ja, also man startet, man startet im Endeffekt Krab und gibt dort als
Kernel-Parameter Init-Bin-Bash ein und zack hat man eine Root-Shell auf dem System, man
muss aber halt physisch dran, und dann kann man drauf, man kann das Root-File-System
Read-Write-Mounten und nachdem man schon Root ist, kann man mit diesem Passwort ein neues
Passwort vergeben, also ich würde es euch zeigen, wenn ich hier eine Linux-Kiste hätte,
aber ich habe keine D-Krab verwendet, ja, und das einzige, was du dagegen machen kannst
ist, oder das offensichtlichste, was du dagegen machen kannst ist, die Festplatte verschlüsseln
und dann musst du dir ein Passwort eingeben, dass du überhaupt Zugriff auf die Festplatte
kriegst, das Mario-Card, oder, ja, Poggers-Card, oh, habe ich hier dann links-off, so, also
wir haben, Next-Loud haben wir gestartet, ich bin im falschen, ich bin, ah, ich blicke
da mal durch, da, da, Moment, was ist das? Habe ich hier auf, ach, das ist was, das die
Baro mal gezeigt hat, hast du eine Meinung zu den Servern Hut von NetCup? Habe ich noch
nie verwendet? NetCup, gucken wir uns doch mal an, wir sind, Moment, was? Was? Was ist
das? Ah, Bild, geh weg, wir sind die Web-Hoster, was stand da gerade? Wir sind die Web-Hoster
des Jahres 2015, wer verleiht das so? Reader's Choice, von was? Hosting und Service Provider
Award 2019, Reader's Choice, von welchem Reader, von was? Hosting und Service Provider Award,
das muss ich jetzt angucken. What? Was soll das sein? Was soll das sein?
Ihre Stimme zählt. Das ist doch so ein Ding, um sich selbst zu feiern, oder? Okay, okay,
die wählen sich, fuck, die wählen sich selbst. Das ist das Service Provider Summit, die wählen
sich einfach selbst. Kein Wunder, dass die alle irgendwelche komischen Awards gewonnen
haben. Ich meine, wenn es jetzt von, sagen wir mal, hätte die EX oder so eine Umfrage
gemacht, dann hätte ich ja noch verstanden. Kannst du ein Tutorial empfehlen, wo es zeigt,
wie ein Debian-Hut-Server mit vollverschlossener Festplatte installieren kann und das Ganze
bei Remote? Das machen wir im Stream. Debian Server Remote installieren, Encryption HDD
und entschlüsseln über SSH. Das machen wir zusammen im Stream. Das ist eine sehr gute
Idee. Bisschen komplizierter, aber auch problemlos machbar. Also als kleiner Hinweis, was relativ
einfach ist, wenn du bei irgendeinem x-beliebigen Hoster bist und schon ein System hast mit
Zugang, nimm das hier, netboot x, y, z, klatsch das drauf, du kannst nämlich direkt dein
Crap damit überschreiben, dann geht dein Crap beim nächsten Boot, macht Networkboot und
dann kannst du einfach den stinknormalen Ubuntu Installer auswählen. Im normalen Ubuntu Installer
kannst du dann auch direkt die Festplatte verschlüsseln lassen und das entschlüsseln
über SSH, weil du musst ja nach dem Reboot einmal ein Passwort eingeben, das machen wir
dann im Stream noch. Wir waren bei Nextcloud, das denkst du. Also zu denen kann ich nichts
sagen hier. Zu denen kann ich nichts sagen, die kenne ich nicht. Ich kann ja mal gucken,
wie die Preise so sind. Bootsauer kenne ich mich nicht aus, was das so kostet. Das ist
ziemlich günstig. 1 Core, 2G RAM, 20G. Das ist relativ günstig. Wenn du mal vergleichst,
die billigste Digital Ocean vm kostet, die aller billigste kostet 5€ im Monat. Dafür
ist das bestimmt nicht abgerechnet. Ich persönlich mag Digital Ocean, das Baro weiß ich schwört
auf Hetzner und demnächst werden wir mal in einem Video, das ist doch was, wir probieren
das mit Hetzner Cloud aus. Das wollte ich schon lange ausprobieren. Hetzner Cloud,
machen wir das. Die wollte ich schon lange ausprobieren. Ja, aber der Preis sieht relativ
günstig aus. Ansonsten kann ich nichts sagen, ob das Qualitätsmerkmal ist, das Chip das
ganze sehr gut getestet hat. Ansonsten kannst du bei den meisten Haustern nicht allzu viel
falsch machen, es sei denn, du gehst zu meinem russischen Low Budget Toaster. Ich glaube,
die kommen aus Russland. Ich habe mir eine VM gekauft vor Jahren, die hat gekostet, ich
weiß es schon gar nicht mehr aus dem Kopf, ich glaube 29$ oder so. 29$ Lifetime, nee
34$ hat sie glaube ich gekostet. 34$ Lifetime VM und habe ich mir gedacht, ja da kann es
ja nichts schief gehen. Du zahlst 34$ und hast für bis an deinem Lebensende eine VM
mit Internet, also mit fester IP und allem. Ja, leider ist das der einzige Provider, der
Reverse SLAs hat. Also der Provider, der ist eher down als up und der sackt halt richtig
das Cloud at Costs. Also nicht da hingehen, ich zeige es jetzt noch mal als Abschreckung,
wo man nicht hingehen sollte. Ja, Datendimit hat man auch. Ich zeige euch jetzt nur, wo
man nicht hingehen sollte. Moment, die haben ein eigenes Reddit. Ja, das sieht ja richtig
professionell aus. Ja, und die hatten mal die, wo sind denn die überhaupt, die Kisten?
Und die hatten zumindest mal Lifetime, Lifetime VM mittlerweile gibt es das anscheinend gar
nicht mehr, keine Ahnung. Und machen jetzt auf seriösen Hoster. Gibt es glaube ich gar
immer hier. Die Musik ist mir gerade zu nervös. Besser. So und. Ja, also die sind wirklich
mies. Die sind wirklich. Was, der erste Beitrag? Crypto Payment, was? Ja, das sagt alles zu
diesem Anbieter, ja. So, also wir wollen den Nextcloud anlegen. Ja, Passport, Admin, äh
äh, ich muss da nochmal Admin, Passport, 123. Guck mal, der Firefox ist ja mittlerweile
schon so clever und kann relativ gute Passwörter generieren, aber wir sagen dem Firefox jetzt
einfach mal knallhart und nehmen 123456. Das ist ein fast sicheres Passwort. Very, very
was? Very weak, das kann nicht sein. Fake News. Das stimmt nicht. Wir wissen alle, dass
123456 eines der besten Passwörter überhaupt ist und ähm, wenn das nichts hilft, nehmen
wir einfach 654321. Es gibt ja Seiten, die erlauben 123456 nicht, dann nehme ich meistens
654321. Das geht dann oftmals. So, installen. Talk, Mail. Ok, der Insta nennt alles standardmäßig,
alles klar, mach, passt, gut. Sound, save, das kann ich auch so nochmal eingeben. Laut
have I been pwned nur 23 Millionen Leaks für 123456. Das erscheint mir fast auch ein bisschen
wenig. Richtig, Matt. Der Matt hat's erkannt. Das Passwort, das wird von so vielen Leuten
verwendet, das kann nicht schlecht sein. Ach, da riecht er noch ein, ok. Dann, mach mal.
Wo wir es gerade von Scam hatten. Build in Codeserver, oh, den probieren wir aus, den
muss ich mir gleich mal aufschreiben. Codeserver, haben die da, haben die da, ist hier noch
ein vias Code oder so noch mit am Start oder was? Ok, der installt noch, da müssen wir
kurz warten. Schauen wir mal so die Auslastung an. Was treibt er denn? Oh, der ist 100% ausgelastet.
Jetzt nicht mehr, jetzt ist er bestimmt fertig. Exzellent, nein ist er nicht. Aber man sieht
auch, woran er gerade dabei ist zu installieren. Ok, ich hab nix gesagt. Talk. Ja vor allem,
ne, der Cancel Button, was soll denn passieren, wenn man auf den Cancel Button klickt? Soll
er sich dann wieder löschen oder wie? Nextcloud Hub, ok, was, was, was gibt's denn tolles
neues? Ok, dass es der gleiche Assistentin schon seit ein paar Versionen gibt. Ja, wunderbar.
Start use in Nextcloud, perfekt. So, das sieht auch noch alles aus wie vorher, nur dass
die, nur dass sie eine neue Schriftart haben oder eine leicht, leicht geupdatete Schriftart,
weil das sieht besser aus wie noch vor ein paar Versionen. Es könnte aber auch an meinem
Lidlx liegen, dass ich da irgendwelche anderen Fonts habe. So, ansonsten ist das noch alles
beim Alten. Fotos, das übliche. Enforre, enfrosch, harambe, Bibliothek, Nextcloud,
Bühne. Aha, ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Also ja, ich sehe, dass es ein Vogel ist,
aber irgendein Papagei oder so, keine Ahnung. Felder. Ein Tug, Moment, das muss ich jetzt
überprüfen, ob das stimmt. Alter, der Chat wieder. Massive Sprain. Ach, das steht auf
dem Bild oben. Ja, gut, das ist aber trotzdem ziemlich big brain, das überhaupt zu lesen.
Wer liest das schon? Wo wir übrigens gerade wieder dabei sind, dass das immer noch Birdie
JPEG oben heißt und wir eigentlich bei Vineyard sind. Wer lesen, allein schon lesen ist. Okay,
das ist das übliche. Das sieht genauso aus wie vorher. Die Mail-App sehe ich absolut
für mich. Kein Anwendungszweck drinnen. Die Mail-App ist nämlich gar keine, gar kein,
das ist nicht so, dass das irgendwie Mails oder so für einen abruft, sondern das ist
eigentlich nur ein Frontend für irgendeinen IMAP. Ist ganz praktisch, wenn man seine Mails
auch über das Webhinterfaces angucken will, ansonsten, das habe ich noch nie großartig
benutzt. So, Kontakt ist wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche. Legen wir mal neuen Kontakt
an, was nicht geht. Okay, neue Kontakt. Vielleicht geht das als Hut nicht. Kann ich keine neuen
Kontakte anlegen? Geht schon gut los. Ja, meinetwegen. Das geht schon gut los. Kann keine
Kontakte anlegen. Ich leg mal einen neuen User an. Ich leg mal einen neuen User an, der
keinen, also der nicht unbedingt... Also warum kann ich keine Kontakte anlegen? Das finde
ich schon mal sehr merkwürdig. Okay, neue User darf ich anlegen. Okay, neue User, Max,
das sieht, Display Name, Max, Passwort, 123456, was sonst? E-Mail, Max at example.com, Ad
Group, Admin. So, excellent. Acht, aiaiai, 123456789, yes. 12345678, a, ups, 12345678,
a. Acht, sieben, sechs, fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins, a. What the fuck? Okay, dann machen
wir jetzt folgendes Passwort. Keck, W, Lull, W. Das ist genau acht Zeichen lang. Ah, okay,
das darf ich, alles gut. Lockout, Max, Keck, W, Lull, W. Gut, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt
User, noch einmal, gucken, ob ich jetzt User anlegen darf, Kontakte. Ah, okay, man darf
bloß keine Kontakte als Admin anlegen. Verstehe. Okay, dann legen wir jetzt mal hier einen
Namen, und zwar, der heißt, kann ich, ich würde gern den Name, ich würde gern den Name, ach,
Twitch. Okay, ähm, wo speichert man? Wo speichert man? Gar nicht, oder? Muss man
nicht, ist automatisch angelegt. Autosave. Jetzt können wir noch ein Picture, Fotos,
die kriegen jetzt, ja, ja, Tukan, kriegt er jetzt. Excellent. So, Q-Chat, da ist er.
Recommendations, okay, Tasks, Tasks will ich auf jeden Fall mal ausprobieren, ob dir jetzt
was taugt. Download and enable. Und dann probieren wir noch das Kanban Board aus. Wenn schon,
dann, dann, dann richtig. Enable. Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Nodes, ja, Nodes muss
auch sein. Enable. Wobei, dafür verwende ich eigentlich andere, andere, äh, Software
für Nodes. Gut, und jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Geschichte. Alter, die Musik
hier kann was. Ist ja gut, ist ja ganz, ganz ruhig. Welche Software benutze für Notizen?
Ich, ich zeig das nachher, ich richte das nachher mal so ein, wie ich, äh, sonst auch
mache. Das da verwende ich hier. Öster. Hat seine Gründe warum, jetzt, ich zeig, zeig
das nachher. Ist die einzige Elektronanwendung, die ich verwende. Die mir jetzt so einfällt,
spontan. Kann eigentlich nicht sein. Im Zweifelsfall verwendet jeder mehr Elektronanwendung, als
er denkt. Und, also gucken wir mal eine Sache, ob die Suche funktioniert. Wo ist denn die
Suche überhaupt hin? Also, wir haben hier einen PDF. Mal gucken, ob wir einen PDF finden,
wo was drinne steht. Also, Developers steht hier drinne. Jetzt kommt es ja fast wie bei
Steve Ball mal vor. Die Developers, die Developers, die Developers. So, suchen, die Developers.
Gut, ok, PDF. PDF-Suche kann ich verstehen, dass die PDF-Suche nicht funktioniert. Was
macht Elektron schlecht? Ähm, ja, es ist halt ein Browser mit einem Fenster drumherum.
Dementsprechend ist das ganze halt RAM-Auslastungsmäßig höher, als es sein müsste für die Einfachheit
der meisten Anwendungen. Ok, dann, wir sind mal nicht so unfilmabern Textdokument. Q-Chat.md.
Ok, md. Standardmäßig. Alles klar. Gibt es auch standardmäßig einen Markdown-Editor.
Ok. Hallo. Oh, sie haben tatsächlich mittlerweile einen halbwegs brauchbaren... Moment. Ist
der Markdown-Editor, kann der, kann der... Splitscreen? Also, dass man auch sehen kann,
das Markdown im Plaintext oder ist es so ein Markdown-Visivic-Verschnitt? Ist PDF nicht
irgendwie Bilder-Internö? Nein, nein. Ich meine, ich finde den Markdown-Editor eigentlich
ganz nett, aber ich mag das, wenn man Markdown im Plaintext sieht. Ich benutze am liebsten
Markdown in Plaintext mit Sündtags-Highlighting. Das finde ich ist die beste Variante. Da
siehst du einfach Plaintext, aber durch Markdown hast du ein bisschen Sündtags-Highlighting,
da sehen deine Überschriften anders aus. So gefällt mir das eigentlich am besten. Poggers-Musik.
Das, äh, genau. Nee, PDF ist auch nicht vector-basiert. PDF ist ein XML-basiertes Dokument-Format.
PDF ist intern ganz viel XML. Okay, äh, was weiß ich, äh, Aja-Jaa-Twitch-Twitch-Chat.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob man die Wörter findet. So, jetzt suchen wir, ob, was, Add-Link,
was macht Add-Link? Äh, Add-Link. Okay, das ist ganz gut gemacht. So, save. Jetzt gucken
wir mal, ob wir das finden. Aja-Jaa. Nö. Okay, die Suche funktioniert standardmäßig nicht.
Das sackt. Gucken wir mal, ob wir das Ganze irgendwie einschalten können. Search. Nope.
Use-Build-In-Code-Server. Was macht das denn? Was? Ach, das war das Liebre-Office, was wir
schon mal ausprobiert haben im Browser. Use-Build-In, aber dann doch nicht so Build-In. Na gut,
vielleicht geht das ja auf. Wenn ich jetzt einen DocX aufmache, kann ich das jetzt bearbeiten
dann zusammen, oder wie ist das? Sollte es eigentlich als Kombi... Ja, ich weiß, dass
es einen Markdown-Editor gibt, den, den kenne ich. Das braucht harte TPS, dann wäre es gut,
wenn mir das das mal irgendwie in einer Fehlermeldung sagen würde. Zumal gerade intern sollte das
eigentlich... Warte, TPS gehen. In der Konsole. Es wirklich Leute gibt, die die Konsole gucken.
Oder du meinst das Log-File. What the fuck? Die haben aber Pläne hier, bis Next-Loud-21.
Okay, was auch immer. Exzellent Fehlermeldung. So, wie kriegt man da eine Suche hin? Wie kriege
ich eine Suche hin? Fehler werden normalerweise unter Protokolliert, unter Einschau... Okay,
dann gucken wir uns das mal an. Settings. Logs. Logging. Was steht hier irgendwas drin? Aha.
Fail to connect localhost 8080. Okay. Habe ich, habe ich das vielleicht nicht installiert,
die App? Use built-in server. Ah, your next cloud setup is not capable of connecting to
demo servers. Ja gut, das ist ja egal. Ich will ja auch mal... Ich will ja auch den built-in
verwenden. Okay, keine Ahnung, das funktioniert aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder nicht. Es
ist aber auch nicht so, dass es ein Feature ist, was ich unbedingt haben will. Was mich
viel eher interessiert ist, wie das mit der Suche funktioniert. So, next-cloud-19-search.
Search. Okay. Ach so, search im Dokument. Add on full-text search. Okay, das ist anscheinend
ein größerer Akt. Warum ist in so einer Software standardmäßig keine Suche drin? Ich finde
das richtig fail. Suchen ist... Also sag mal so, Sachen finden ist eigentlich fast wichtiger
als alle anderen Features zusammen. So, also wir gehen jetzt mal kurz hier in die Apps
hinzufügen, gucken, ob man da irgendwie Suche hinzufügen kann. Search. Full-text search.
Ach, da unten gibt es sogar ein extra Kategorie-Versuche. Okay, search. Also was haben wir denn da? Full-text
search. Man kann sogar, guck mal, da an sich ist das richtig big brain, da kann sogar Bilderkennung
machen und dann kann man die durchsuchen. So. Full-text of your files. Full-text, okay.
Welches? Davon jetzt? Okay, full-text files. Files reicht ja schon mal. Gut, dann gehen
wir mal in die Settings und gucken, ob wir das da... Oder vielleicht geht es jetzt ja
schon. Ah, ja, ja. Würde mich aber wundern. Nein, natürlich nicht. Settings. Search.
Okay. Next cloud. Search. Dass man ein Tutorial braucht, um... Search. Okay, search. Okay,
search. Ah, hier, da. Heute möchte ich euch erklären, wie bei einer extra die Suche full-text
search. Full-text search. Blablabla. Oh, man muss Elasticsearch selbst installieren.
Oh, nee. Ach, nee. Also, aber der ganze Abgesehen davon, dass ich das im Container jetzt gar
nicht machen kann. Okay, das ist immer noch eklig. Das ist immer noch eklig. Das gefällt
mir immer noch nicht. Ich meine, ich kann mal das Elasticsearch-Ding installieren, aber
das wird wahrscheinlich alleine nicht reichen. Settings. Full-text search. Ja, und da muss
man jetzt Elasticsearch... Das könnte man schöner machen. Da muss es irgendwas eingebautes
geben. Ich finde, das sollte man den meisten Leuten nicht zumuten, ihre eigene Search
aufsetzen zu müssen. Ah, so weit ist es in dem Container gar nicht kann. Ich kann jetzt
irgendwas anderes angeben. Klar, ich kann mir auch ein schönes Docker-Compose-File machen,
was das macht. Ich glaube mal, es ist gar nicht so schwierig, wenn man sich hier das
Tutorial anguckt, sieht es auch relativ übersichtlich aus. Aber, dass das nicht standardmäßig eine
Suche drin hat, finde ich fail. Oder zumindest per einem Klick aktiviert werden kann. Das
finde ich ziemlich fail. Ich habe eigentlich gehofft, dass es besser ist als das letzte
Mal, wo ich es ausprobiert habe. Add Nodes, Lists or Links? Poggers? Was passiert jetzt?
Was ist das für ein... Was ist das? Das ist einfach ein randomen Editor jetzt. Wofür
ist der da? Vor allem, was editiere ich damit und wo speichert er es? Man weiß es nicht
genau. Um schnell Notizen zu adden. Du meinst, man kann das jetzt adden als File? Nö. Hä?
Ich verstehe es wirklich nicht. Ist die ReadMeTXT? Ach. Okay, dann finde ich es gar nicht so
übel. Also sprich, wenn man eine ReadMeTXT drin... Aber das ist auch ganz schön magic.
Was zum Teufel ist mit dem... Ah! Was ist... Ich habe den Editor kaputt gemacht. Der Editor
ist broken. Hallo. An sich finde ich das Feature nicht schlecht. Das ist mal, um ganz schnell
Notizen zu machen, die dann in der ReadMe-Markt dauernd... Das ist gar nicht so... Das finde
ich eigentlich ganz nett, ja. Ist doch eigentlich okay. Mich irritiert, dass man das hier bearbeiten
kann, anstatt dass es die ReadMe von dem Ordner einfach anzeigt. Aber das Feature finde ich
gar nicht so übel. So, was haben wir hier als Sonstes noch Schönes? Also, dass die Suche
nicht funktioniert, enttäuscht mich schon. Weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock
hier mein eigenes Elasticsearch und gedönstete. Klar, kann ich alles machen, aber ich finde
es von der Usability nicht schön, dass man nicht standardmäßig eine Suche dabei hat.
Oder zumindest eine Suche total einfach... Enablen kann, die dann einfach tut. Ich meine,
klar, das muss ja nicht die ausgefeilte Suche sein. Aber Plain Text Dateien, Inhalt finden,
das sollte Build-In sein. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, als wäre sowas schwierig zu programmieren.
Plain Text Dateien, im Zweifelsfall machst du unter der Haube den EXEC im Grab drinnen,
wenn du es auf dem Linux hast. Also, so kann das nicht sein. So, was haben wir noch? Fotos
haben wir schon angeguckt. Das ist ja seit Jahren gleich. Activities, das was man erwarten
würde. Ach guck mal, man sieht jetzt auch... Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Übersicht,
dass man hier alles jetzt hat. So, Talk werde ich nicht verwenden. New in Talk. Kann es
Twitch Emotes? Nein, ganz natürlich nicht. Das hätte mich jetzt positiv überrascht.
Natürlich kann es keine Twitch Emotes. Das wäre auch sehr merkwürdig. Was kreiselt
hier eigentlich ein App gerade? Okay, ich weiß nicht was kreiselt, aber kreiselt grind.
Leave Conversation. Oh. Yep. Conversation. Lul. Der Admin, den Admin lade ich auch noch
dazu ein. Ja, genau. Hi Admin. Wenn der jetzt antwortet, mache ich mir Gedanken. Pass auf,
gleich steht hier unten, Admin schreibt gerade. So, Mail hatten wir schon. Kontakte, wie gehabt.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, dass ich noch das Kontakte-Interface mit am besten finde.
Kalender wahrscheinlich auch wie gehabt. Sieht ein bisschen anders aus als sonst. Icy sagt,
die Foto-App ist ultra-prog, wenn man ein Ordner bzw. eine Galerie mit mehr als 100
Bildern oder so hat, dann macht er einfach übelst viele SQL-Connections auf und überschreibt.
Echt jetzt? Über 100 Bilder ist jetzt natürlich wirklich das Problem. Das können wir gleich
machen. Das machen wir gleich. Ich kopiere einfach den Frosch 1000 Mal da rein. Das probieren
wir gleich aus. Das probieren wir gleich aus. Ne, wir machen MonkaS als Bild rein, kopieren
es 1000 Mal, nicht den Frosch. Aber ich war noch gut. Kalender muss ich mir nicht groß
seit angucken, ist wahrscheinlich wie gehabt gleich geblieben. So, jetzt gibt es das komische
Deck für Leute, die hier Kanbonn-Pros sind. Kanbonn-Pros, ja. Die können jetzt, was kann
man hier schönes machen? List name, kecken, keck wen. Was kann man jetzt hier, ne Moment,
wie geht das jetzt? Add card, 0w größer, heckw. So, und das kann man jetzt, ne. Moment,
wie kann man das jetzt track und dropen? Ach so hier. Das war auch schon mal fail, dass
ich nicht unten drunter tracken kann, oder? Oder habe ich den Kanbonn-Sinn nicht verstanden?
Warum kann ich das nicht hier runter tracken? Hä, jetzt gehts. What the hell? Dem Kram fehlt
der Polish. Ich kann machen, was ich will. Ich werde mit den eingebauten Apps nicht verahmen.
Manchmal gehts. What the fuck? Ok, ich verstehe das nicht. Es ist alles halbherzig gemacht.
Das ist auch genau den Eindruck, das ist das, warum mir schon seit on cloud das ganze nicht
gefällt. Erstmal 3 Wochen BWL-Kurs. Ja, dass man richtig Kanbonnen kann. Wenn man es oben
drüber macht, geht das lustigerweise. Oben drüber, oben drüber, gar kein Problem. Unten
drunter, teilweise procken. Hallo? What the fuck? Ok, das mag nicht. Gut, ich brauche hier
kein Kanbonn-Board. Warum hängt es jetzt an meinem Auszeiger? Ich habe die Maus gar nicht
mehr gedrückt. Personal, die nehmen es persönlich. Ah gut. Stell dich noch nicht so an, zieh das
nicht einen halben Meter runter, sondern direkt runter. What? Ich habe das direkt hier drunter
geschoben. Guck mal. Wo soll ich das noch hinschieben? Na gut, haben wir das ausprobiert.
Das wollte ich aber eh nicht verwenden. So, und jetzt kommen wir zu meinen zwei Sachen,
die ich wirklich liebend gerne in Nextcloud verwenden würde, die aber nie richtig zufriedenstellend
funktioniert haben. Das erste sind Notizen. So, und die ganze Zeit war das Problem, dass
man das nicht durchsuchen kann. Ich glaube, das geht mittlerweile. Machen wir nochmal
eine neue Note, die irgendwie einfach nur Müll drinne stehen hat. So, und jetzt suchen
wir mal nach POC like this. Ok, das geht auch nicht. Wozu brauche ich Notizen, die ich
nicht durchsuchen kann? Es ist doch einfach useless. Es tut mir leid. Ich meine, ich
habe da großen Respekt vor, dass die Leute diesen Kram entwickeln. Seit Jahren schon.
Also kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass ich erst in Elasticsearch aufsetzen muss, dass
ich POC like this in einer Notiz durchsuchen kann. Merkt ihr einfach, wo sie stehen. Big
brain. Hopp, keine Chance. Ok, ist das vielleicht der Sucheknopf woanders? Die Sache ist die,
kann die Elasticsearch überhaupt Notes durchsuchen? GitHub, Notes, App, Nextcloud. Vielleicht
brauchen die Quotes. Das glaube ich nicht. Achso, das Dokument heißt so. Ah, Dateinahmesuchen
geht natürlich. Also wenn ich QtChats suche, das findet er. Aber ich will doch von Notes
den Inhalt suchen, nicht die Dateinahme. Ah, das ist doch blöd. So, suchen wir mal hier,
ob die Notes App sowas überhaupt unterstützt. Search. Highlight Search Results. Ok, der
kann anscheinend suchen. Signs, there is an ability to search. Echt jetzt? Wie, Moment.
Hä? Ja wie, ist das jetzt implementiert oder nicht? Simple Search Functionality. 2016?
Das haben sie wahrscheinlich rausgeschmissen zwischendurch. Oder ist das die Dateinsuche?
Noch mal zu mitmeißeln, schon mal mit dem offiziellen Docker probiert. Vorhin schon erwähnt,
dass in dem Linux Server Image so einige Sachen nicht funktionieren. Äh, das ist das offizielle
Docker, Alter. Das ist das offizielle Docker, was ich verwende. Ich hab gar nicht das Linux
Server Image verwendet. Das ist offizieller geht es nicht. Du kannst dich an der Nextcloud
Entwicklung beteiligen. Eventuell wird es dann stabiler und besser. Äh, nö. Ich würd's
einfach nur gern benutzen. Das ist aber doof, dass das keine Suche hier drin geht. Ich
mein, wozu eine Notiz App ohne Suche? Das ist irgendwie kacke. Naja, gut. Naja, äh,
muss ich mich wieder abfinden, dass es nicht funktioniert. Äh, was ich mich jetzt nur
noch frage ist. Mal angenommen, ich würd' nen Elastic Search installieren. Würde sich
dann die, hat es jemand von euch vielleicht? Äh, würde sich dann das in den Elastic Search
integrieren? Was will er denn eigentlich? Ich will gar nichts einrichten. Ich will die
Nodes App verwenden. Ich will die Nodes App verwenden und in der Nodes App suchen. Wo
ich der Ansicht bin, dass eine Nodes App, äh, eine Suche unterstützen sollte. Und wenn
ich jetzt in einem, in einer Notiz was suchen will, dann find ich nix. Gibt es nicht sogar
einen Elastic Container? Doch, das ist relativ simpel. Aber ich will mir gar kein eigenes
Elastic Search einrichten, nur dass ich meine Notizen durchsuchen kann. Gibt es nicht,
nur Titel? Das hab ich gemerkt, dass nur Titel funkt. Das, das, das geht ja. Das geht ja
seit Jahren schon. Ich hab ja den Kram schon lange laufen, aber ich, ich wollt' ihm mal
noch ne Chance geben, weil ich halt die meisten Teile von Nextcloud nicht verwende. Deswegen
bin ich schon die ganze Zeit am Überlegen, ob ich das nicht einfach austausch durch irgendwas
anderes, durch irgendwas total Simples, was nur File Sync macht und fertig. Ähm, und
ich wollt' jetzt einfach mal gucken, hat sich das irgendwie verbessert, aber das wirkt
an vielen Stellen mega halbherzig. Äh, Laibumster? Äh, naja, nicht, also, also ich find' nicht,
dass Hira eine gute Alternative ist für, ähm, ne Notiz App. Hira ist ein gutes Ticketsystem,
was übrigens ziemlich günstig ist. Das kostet nur 10 Dollar. Also das kann man sich wirklich,
also wenn man sowas, wenn man das mag, kann man sich das wirklich leisten. Das ist total
billig für daheim. Ich, ja, ich weiß, man kann sich den Fulltext allerdings nur reinhauen,
wenn man sich den eigenen Elasticsearch aufsetzt dabei. Guck mal, es, es, es ist sogar mittlerweile
kostenlos für bis zu 10 Benutzer. Guck mal. Also, ist sogar noch billiger geworden. Na,
ich hab' den Kram ja schon installiert. Ich hab' ja schon das ganze Fulltext Zeug installiert,
aber dazu brauch' ich noch ein Elasticsearch, dass es funktioniert. Und da hab' ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock drauf. Ja, wirkt alles ein bisschen halbgar. So, eine Sache,
die ich, äh, noch machen wollte, war, ich muss mal gucken, ich hab' mal was aufgeschrieben.
Genau, den, äh, den Desktop Client. Ja, bis zu 10 User. Wie gesagt, ich wusste nicht,
dass das hier kostenlos mittlerweile ist, aber das hat schon vor Jahren nur 10 Dollar gekostet.
So, wir installieren uns jetzt mal den, den Desktop Client. Ich weiß, dass ein Elasticsearch
nicht schwierig aufzusetzen ist. Ich find's aber blöd, dass das einfach zumindest nicht
mal eine Basicsuche in Notizen standardmäßig mit drin ist oder zumindest eine Basicsuche
wie bei Plain Text Dateien. Das wär' ja nur wirklich nicht, äh, nur wirklich kein
großer Akt. Im Zweifelsfall würden sie irgendeinen EXAC machen, wo dann CREP reingeht oder so.
Äh, gibt es eigentlich irgendwas, mit dem man ordentlich Kalendersynken kann oder ist
das nur über den Google oder ähnlichen Kram praktikabel? Für Kalendersynken ist CalDAF
tatsächlich nie übel. Das funktioniert ziemlich gut. Ähm, wenn man halt einen Client hat,
der das Ganze unterstützt. Wenn man, sagen wir mal, Thunderbird verwendet, was ist ja,
kriegst du ja für alle Betriebssysteme, wunderbar. IOS Kalender kann auch CalDAF synken und
äh, Android kann's auch. Also, CalDAF kann man für Kalender wirklich verwenden. Das ist
okay. Wenn man dann bisschen advancedere Sachen haben will, wie beispielsweise die, äh, wie
beispielsweise To-Do-Tasks mit Notifications, dann wird's schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Äh, gibt es denn eine gute Open Source Alternative, insbesondere mit der Möglichkeit, Files in
den Cloud abzulegen und einfach mit anderen zu shurnen? Also, wenn du es mit anderen
Benutzern verwenden willst, ist Nextcloud ziemlich gut. Ich weiß, ich glaub nicht, dass es da
eine gute, eine sinnvolle Alternative gibt. Aber ich benutze das eh nur allein, beziehungsweise
alles nur hier bei mir im Netzwerk. Ähm, und ich brauch ja im Prinzip, den CalDAF bräuchte
ich noch nicht mal wirklich, ja. Ähm, das ist ganz nett, aber ich hab nicht so viele
Kalendereinträge, dass das jetzt irgendwie... Also, im Zweifels gibt's ja auch CalDAF Server
mit einem Befehl gestartet und sonst wo. Ähm, aber den Filesync, da hab ich das hier aktuell
im Auge. Wenn ich eh von Nextcloud nur 10% verwende, vielleicht soll ich's auch ganz
abschaffen. Weil ich werd, ich werd mit der, ich werd seit Jahren mit Nextcloud einfach
nicht warm. Nee, vor allem mit extern. Äh, pff. Ich glaub, das geht mittlerweile ganz
gut in Nextcloud. Pile auch mit extern shurn. Hab ich noch nie gemacht. Also gut, das muss
ja von außen erreichbar sein, irgendwie. Du hast dich auch von Nextcloud verabschiedet,
aber dir, aber dir der Grund. Also meine Sache ist, also das, was mir halt nicht gefällt
ist, das wirkt einfach so halbherzig an vielen Stellen. Das ist, zu 90% ist das gut gemacht
und ist auch, ist auch gut genug durchdacht, aber so, das Polish fehlt irgendwie einfach.
Wenn du dann schon siehst, dass hier die Menüs teilweise reinklitschen, dass du standardmäßig
nicht mal ne rudimentäre Suche hast und, und allein schon das track und drop in diesem
komischen Kanmbarn-Bot nicht richtig funktioniert, war, ist irgendwie so, dass das Polish fehlt
einfach. So, jetzt nehmen wir den Nextcloud client, falls's den irgendwo gibt, 11. Oh,
ich glaube, ich müsste mal wieder OS-Update machen. Ok, ich mach mal kurz OS-Update. Geht
hoffentlich schnell. Moin, Chris. Wie lange hab ich das Ding schon einmal geupdatet? NoahP
seh ich genauso. Ja, genau den Eindruck hab ich auch. Genau, genau, die machen Features
ohne Ende kommen rein. Jetzt gibt es irgendwie ne Voice-Chat-App, ne Chat-App, ne Kanmbarn-Bot,
haste nicht gesehen, alles Mögliche drin. Das ist Manjaro. Alles Mögliche drin, aber
irgendwie die Sachen, gute Ansätze, aber einfach, es geht einfach manchmal über Basics,
da sind noch nicht mal die Basics drin. Beispiel rudimentäre Suche von Notizen. Das ist irgendwie
nix, nix richtig polished einfach. Also, wie gesagt, ich verwende den Gramm ja schon seit
onCloud und ich hab seit Anfang an den gleichen Eindruck. Irgendwie wird das nicht besser.
Wunder mich jedes Mal, wie easy Updates unter Liedung sind, wenn man den Müll von Microsoft
dagegen überstellt, sagt Dro M. Ja. Und du musst nur mal Colonel Update neu starten.
Ich weiß, da gibt es Tricks, dass es zum Teil auch geht, wobei komplette Colonel Updates
eigentlich nie ohne Neustart gehen. Ja, aber im Vergleich zu Windows 10 Updates ist das
schon easy. Der Vorteil hiervon ist aber auch, dass das Rolling Release mit n bisschen verzögerten
Repos ist. Also du hast nicht hier volles Bleeding Edge wie bei Arch Linux, sondern die
Pakete sind so zwei Wochen verzögert. OnCloud wird doch noch weiterentwickelt, fix mal reinschauen.
Ne, da hat sich noch weniger getan als bei Nextcloud. Muss erst mal die Basics machen.
So ist es, müssten sie machen. Und dann auf den Mount Everest. Ne, geht nicht. Der Vorteil
gerade bei Mancharo ist ja auch, dass das Rolling Release ist. Also sprich, du machst
nicht nur einmal im Jahr oder einmal im halben Jahr Update, du machst eigentlich permanent
zweimal die Woche oder so Update und dann ist es auch nicht so viel. Ich hab jetzt hier
schon eine Weile immer gemacht. Ja. Aber im Vergleich zu der halben, was heißt zu der
halben, zu der kompletten Neuinstallation, was ja viele Windows Updates sind, hat Werner
einen Tipp für eine ordentliche Groupware. Das sind so Softwarebereiche, da hab ich echt
keinen Plan von. Der Knüpfelklingel soll einfach, dass das Hard Service läuft wieder.
Exzellent. Discord Groupware, beste. Ne, da kenn ich mich nicht aus, da kenn ich mich
nicht gut aus, was sowas angeht. Linux 57, ja die sind jetzt auf Chrome Versionierung
umgestellt. Die haben gesehen, das kann nicht sein, dass Browser bei Version 80 sind. Jetzt
gibt es auch Linux 57, die holen auf. Demnächst Discord for Business. Da gibt es ja schon Teams
für, auch wenn Teams absolut Null mit Discord mithalten kann, was die Funktionalität angeht.
Allein schon das ganze rumgestelle immer am Mikro. Gira ist super, also als Ticketsystem
ist super. Das ist eine der wenigen Geschichten, wo ich tatsächlich mir das ganze kaufen würde,
auch wenn es ein bisschen teurer wäre. Also wenn ich das brauchen will. Mittlerweile
haben wir gesehen, der Kram ist sogar kostenlos für unter 10 Leute. Das finde ich super.
Wir hatten schon ein paar Ticketsysteme. Das allererste Ticketsystem, das war, wo ich
damals noch bei Provider gearbeitet habe, das war entweder war das irgendwas selbstgestricktes
oder irgendwas PHP basiertes sehr heavy customized. Was gibt es denn so für Open Source Ticketsysteme?
US Ticket oder sowas? Gab es doch. Und ich glaube davon hatten die irgendwas angepasstes
gehabt, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher. Das war grausam. Das war grausam. Das war
grausam. Danach hatten sie so ein integriertes Ding mit ein bisschen Nagios dabei und sowas
ganz Abenteuerliches auch zum größten selbst gebastelt. Bei der Firma, wo ich jetzt bin,
hatten wir am Anfang noch ein Notes basiertes Ticketsystem. Also das ist ja wirklich weird
Jam. Da musstest du im Notes Tickets aufmachen und dann haben sie sich endlich mal was richtiges
gekauft und haben vor ein paar Jahren sich eine ordentliche fette Jira Lizenz, jetzt
fange ich auch schon an Jira zu sagen, das heißt Jira, Jira Lizenz gekauft und da muss
ich sagen von allen, von allen Müllsoftware Produkten, die wir im Einsatz haben, ist Jira
noch das wenigstens am wenigsten müllige. AC2013 sagt suche einen Ersatz für Google
und Co Kalender Notizen, Kontakte, Fotos, Files. Ja in der Theorie her Nextcloud in
der Praxis bei weitem nicht und das sage ich sogar noch zu Google Produkten, in der Praxis
halt nicht so schön zu bedienen und nicht so polished wie Google, wobei Google Produkte
und polished ist so, das drehen sich dann, ne, aber auf jeden Fall nicht so easy wie
mit Google. Was ich gerade mache, ich habe gerade Nextcloud ausprobiert. Nextcloud ist
entgegen dem, wie es heißt, eigentlich hat es mit Cloud überhaupt nichts zu tun, ist
eine PHP Anwendung, über die man Dateien sünden kann, Kalender sünden kann und Kontakte
sünden kann, jetzt mal ganz billig gesagt. Und bloß, dass die noch 30 Milliarden Zusatzfunktionen
haben, hat von denen alles nur sehr halbherzig funktioniert. Ja, AC is so. Also rein, rein
vom, von der Einfachheit her, von wie Cross-Platform die Sachen verfügbar sind, muss man halt echt
sagen, da sind sowohl die Google Geschichten als auch so die üblichen Verdächtigen von
angefangen von Dropbox, was FileSync angeht, oder auch was wäre es, das Ding von Microsoft,
schön vergessen. Oder auch die Office-Strate-65-Geschichte, wenn meinetwegen wirklich irgendjemand Office
verwenden will, da gibt es halt nichts Vergleichbares, Open Source-technisches. Oh Gott, SharePoint,
hör mal auf. Warum benutzt du das anstelle von OneDrive oder iCloud? Äh, weil man das
bei sich selbst betreiben kann. So, warte mal, jetzt haben wir den Nextcloud Client installiert.
Ich wollte jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob die, ah ne, Moment, ich hab ein Priv-Stream-Update
gemacht, ich hab den Nextcloud nicht installiert. Nextcloud Client, Nextcloud Client 11, zack.
Massive Passwort. Man muss sagen, die Desktop-Clients mittlerweile, die sind ganz okay. Der Blog-Watcher
sagt, das Backup-Sync-Programm von Google für Winners ist der größte Rotzer, okay,
das hab ich auch nicht verwendet. Ich verwende nichts davon, so wirklich. So, aktuell verwende
ich halt zum File-Sync, Nextcloud für Kalender, auch noch Nextcloud, Kontaktesync, theoretisch
Nextcloud, wobei ich da relativ, ihr kennt mich, wenig Kontakte-Synke. Und für Notes
und To-Do's verwende ich halt den hier. Das kann ich euch auch gleich nochmal zeigen.
So, Login, Host, Local Host, Port 8080, Moment. Ja, wir haben, ach ne, HTTP, alles klar, Next.
Und wenn man es noch richtig schreibt, IP League, MonkaS, jetzt ist raus, Leute. Seid
ihr schon drin. XFaitl 1337, 13 Monate und ist aktuell im 13. fortlaufenden Monat, das
ist ja wahrlich exzellent. BigBrain-Subscription. Okay, Login, Max, keqw0w, never. Okay, wenigstens,
das funktioniert gut. Sync everything, machen wir. Home, Free Space, Connect. Perfekt. Gut.
So, dann probieren wir mal aus, ob das wirklich abkackt, wenn man da 5000 Bilder rein macht.
Okay, warum auch immer. Okay, also, MonkaS. MonkaS als GIF. Transparent. MonkaS. Okay,
ist das transparent? Ja, wunderbar. So. MonakS. Ne. So, mal gucken, wie der Sync funktioniert
jetzt. So, und das Ganze machen wir jetzt in Fotos. Nach Fotos. Und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt, ob das stimmt, was irgendjemand im Chat gesagt hat, dass das jetzt abkackt,
wenn man da zu viele Fotos rein macht. Weil normalerweise würde ich jetzt erwarten, dass
das, keine Ahnung, entweder ein Paging hat unten, 1 bis 60 Seiten, oder das, was jetzt
gerade modern ist, Endless Scroll. Brick, zwei Monate, Dankeschön, Subscription, huge.
So, uploadet er das Foto heute nochmal? Ne, macht er nicht. By the way, warum nicht?
Sync MonkaS? Und ergeblich hat er es gesynced. Da ist es doch. Wo ist es denn? Ist es das
hier? Wo ist es? Ne, ne, ne. Drittes Bild. Ist klar, Chat. Wo ist es denn? Huh. Rate
me. Okay, es wird ja wohl, es wird ja nicht dran liegen, dass es ein PNG ist, oder? Okay,
cpfrog0.jpg. Schauen wir mal. Da ist es. Jetzt! Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Das geht
gar nicht. Das geht gar nicht. Das geht gar nicht. Du hast gerade aus dem jpg, jpg, ich
weiß, ich weiß, es war Absicht, es geht. Ne, ne, ne, das kann nicht sein. Das glaube
ich nicht. Convert. Moment. Image, Magic installieren. Image, Magic, Image, Magic.
Konvertieren das jetzt. Link am Bild. MonkaS ist blacklisted. Vielleicht. Ich glaube, das
Bild ist zu groß. Ich glaube, das Bild ist zu groß. Guck mal, das Bild ist 2800x2011.
Allerdings muss das trotzdem funktionieren, weil Fotos, die da jemand drin ablegt, die
sind ja auch so groß. Okay, Convert. Was zum Teufel ist Convert HD? Ah, Besse, gibt
kein Manpage-Eintrag, Help gibt es auch nicht. Irgendeine. Okay, Convert, also MonkaS zu
MonkaS.jpg. Kann es? Jetzt ernsthaft? Ist das euer?
Das glaube ich, ich kann es nicht fassen. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass das kein PLG
anzeigen kann. Die Transparenz. Ja, aber, okay, okay, vielleicht klickt es an der Transparenz.
Okay, wir suchen uns ein MonkaS raus. MonkaS ohne Transparenz. Alles klar. Ja, aber trotzdem,
wo ist das Problem an Transparenz? Das ist meinem Browser doch scheißegal. Mein Browser
kam das seit 1991. Das ist alles transparent. Okay, ich nehme jetzt einfach das. Nextcloud
recognize PLGs nicht als PLGs. Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn? Okay, Nextcloud. Das
ist doch nicht euer Ernst. Okay, das bestätigt genau das, was ich die ganze Zeit sage. Das
ist einfach absolut unpolished und halbherzig, der ganze Kram. PLGs, ich meine, wir sind,
es ist eigentlich egal welches Jahr, ich sage, PLG ist halt immer da gefühlt. Ich bin auf
die Welt gekommen, PLG war da, ja. Nee, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht. PLG, wann
ist denn das rausgekommen? Keine Ahnung. Paar 90, 95 oder so. 96, ja. Gut, da gab es
mich schon 12 Jahre, aber trotzdem. Ich meine, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst. PLGs aren't
recognized as photos. Ist die Frage sein Ernst?
Was ist das für eine Frage? Why do you have PNG-Fotos? Weil ich PNG-Fotos habe, muss man
das, na egal. Das ist doch nicht, die Anfahrt, oh, da könnte ich mich drüber aufregen jetzt.
What the fuck? Okay, er schreibt das wenigstens nett, ich will mich ja nicht zu sehr drüber
beschweren. Also ganz ehrlich, die Frage stellt sich doch gar nicht. Wenn ich ein PNG, also
ein Bild, wenn ich irgendein Bildformat in meinen Fotosordner ablege, dann sollte das
im Web angezeigt werden, sofern der Browser das kann.
Was ist das für ein PNG-Fotos? Was ist das für ein PNG-Fotos?
Was ist das für ein PNG-Fotos? Was zur Hölle ist das für ein PNG-Fotos?
Was? Los geht's què?
embarrassed
machen. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt immer mehr davon wegkomme, irgendeine Komplettlösung
zu verwenden, sondern ich werde in Zukunft höchstwahrscheinlich folgendes machen. Ich
benutze Zynkthing für FileZynk und nehme irgendeinen billigen Kaldorf Server für Kalender
und fertig. Da fährst du wahrscheinlich besser mit. Das ist vom April. Scheint ja hoch,
kritisches, hochdiskutiertes Feature zu sein, dass da jetzt ein halbes Jahr rumgammelt,
dass PNGs unterstützt werden. Ich finde es aber gut, die sind allewegs normal nett zueinander. Ist
auch vollkommen egal, ob das ein Foto Format ist oder nicht. Wenn man ein Bild, was der Browser
anzeigen kann, in den Fotos-Ordner schiebt, dann soll das einfach angezeigt werden. Ich
verstehe die ganze Diskussion darüber nicht. Und ich kann auch ohne Probleme PNG-Fotos haben.
Also ich kann mir doch ein Foto aus dem Hintergrund laden, weil es mir toll gefällt,
also was weiß ich, Desktop-Hintergrund oder so. Also die Diskussion, ob PNG nur supported ist
oder nicht, finde ich vollkommen überflüssig. Fotos-Ordner-Ungleich-Fotos-App. Ja, aber die
Fotos-App verwendet den Fotos-Ordner. Und wenn ich so blöd bin und irgendein bescheuertes Format in
den Foto-Ordner reinschiebe, was nicht richtig funktioniert, da habe ich halt Pech. Die Diskussion
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Außerdem muss man auch mal sagen, das heißt zwar Fotos,
ja. Aber man könnte es auch sowas wie Galerie nennen. Ach Fotos durchsucht alle Ordner. Dann
sollte man das konfigurierbar machen. Kann man das einstellen? Welche? Dann sollte man das
konfigurierbar machen. Okay, das ist ja noch blöder. Wenn das alles nimmt, was da ist.
Dann sollte man es zumindest konfigurierbar machen. Entweder, dass man sagt, der Ordner,
dass man den Ordner auswählen kann. Weil ich will das gar nicht. Vielleicht lade ich da
irgendwas hoch, wo PNGs drin sind. Oder zumindest, dass man es ausschalten kann. Dann
könnte man auch gleich eine Option einbauen. Ja, ich will auch PNGs haben. Aber das PNG ist
nicht unterstützt. Fail. So, aber wir sind ja auf einen anderen Weg dahin gekommen.
Und zwar, dass jemand gemeint hat, das würde kaputt gehen, wenn man da viele Bilder reinmacht.
Und nachdem ich mir das jetzt angeguckt habe, gehe ich davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich
sogar stimmt. Probieren wir mal aus. Geh mal auf Your Albums, okay. Ach da, okay. Verstehe,
deswegen ist hier auch der... Ja, aber dann gefällt mir die Photos App gar nicht. Ich
will ja wirklich den Ordner angeben, wo ich meine Fotos habe. Es ist ja auch schon ein
bisschen verwirrend, ne. Wenn es da einen Fotos Ordner gibt, aber die Fotos App standardmäßig
auf alles geht. Ich verstehe warum das so ist und ich finde es auch nicht verkehrt, dass
das Default ist. Aber das sollte man zumindest konfigurierbar machen. Gibt es denn eine Galerie
App, die das besser kann? Kommen wir mal, vielleicht. Okay, Files, was gibt es da sonst noch so?
PDR Viewer. Ja, ein MP4 ist ein Foto, klar. Was sonst? Ne, in Nextcloud Logik bestimmt
nicht. Nein, nicht User. MP4 sind einfach viele enander encodete Fotos mit Sound, genau.
Nextcloud Galerie App. Hallo? Nein. Und vor allem, warum ist das? Fucking Bing! Warum
hab ich hier Bing als Default noch drin? Galerie App. Ah, Moment. Pictures App has been improved
now called Galerie App. Das haben sie schon wieder geändert, oder? Galerie App heißt
mittlerweile wieder Fotos. Galerie gibt es ja hier, ne. Das heißt bestimmt mittlerweile
wieder Fotos. Ja, ich hab gesehen, dass das Nextcloud 17 ist, aber ich hätte gedacht,
vielleicht das ist mit 19 auch noch so, aber anscheinend war 19 jetzt immer noch drin.
Ja, aber es gibt gar keine Galerie App. Galerie App has been replaced by Fotos. Okay, nur
da ich das richtig verstehe, Fotos wurde ersetzt durch Galerie und jetzt wurde Galerie wieder
ersetzt durch Fotos. Sehe ich das richtig, ja? Ah, yes! Okay, das verwirrt mich. Okay,
also wir machen jetzt mal, also CP, was nehmen wir denn jetzt? MonkaS, JPEG. MonkaS, JPEG.
Und das nennen wir jetzt, was weiß ich, OmegaLUL. Warum eigentlich? Wir nennen es einfach
auch wieder MonkaS. Und dann, wie viel machen wir denn erstmal, Leute? Ja, wir machen erstmal
100, oder? Äh, Moment, ging das mit CP nicht? Moment, wie ging das nochmal? Äh. Ah, mit
Touch ging das, oder? Oder hab ich jetzt das falsch im Kopf? Ja, oder? Mit Touch geht's.
Ja, ich dachte, mit CP kann man das auch machen. Anscheinend nicht. CP, Expansion oder irgendwie
sowas. Weiß ich nicht, ob das sowas kann. Ich hab, wir können, wir können eine Schleife,
wir können, wir können, äh, wir können eine Schleife machen. Aber ich dachte, geht das
wirklich nicht? Ja, genau, mit einer Schleife, ist klar, dass das funktioniert. Hätte ich
hätte wecken können, dass das mit CP eigentlich funktioniert. Ok, Bash, Sequence, CP, weil,
ok, wir müssen das mal von Hand ausbringen. Ich kann doch, das funktioniert ja nur, wenn
das hier auch funktioniert. Im Endeffekt macht das ja unter der Haube das. Ok, dann weiß
ich, warum es nicht funktioniert. Das ist ja im Prinzip Bash-Magic, das sieht ja das
CP-Commando gar nicht. Achso, das hat er jetzt gar nicht gemacht. Finde ich aber merkwürdig.
Ja, das ist mit Fein zusammen, ha? Interessant. Ja, also mit einer Schleife geht's auf jeden
Fall. Mit T wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht, wie ich's machen soll. Ich könnte, doch, doch
klar, ich könnte sagen, hier MonkaS, S-Dings, dann das ganze nach T, ähm, so, dann splitte
da das und kann ich's jetzt direkt hinten dran schreiben? Ach, Quatsch, ich muss ja
den Standard-Out umleiten, null. Tatsächlich, exellent. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob der
MonkaS, er hat gesyncht. Mal gucken, ob's jetzt abkackt. Oh, da ist es. Ok, noch, noch
geht alles. Mini-Monka. Gibt es, Moment, gibt es das? Gibt es das als, als, als, als
Evolved, Emote, Mini-MonkaS? Gut, dann machen wir mal ein bisschen mehr. Machen wir mal
langsam, mal langsam. Hat er gesyncht? Oder immerhin, der SYNCHT, er SYNCHT, er SYNCHT
noch. Ich, ich geb ihm mal kurz Zeit zu SYNCHTEN. Zumindest, zumindest verschluckt sich der SYNCHT
schon mal nicht. What? Ah, ich hab ja geupdatet. Oh, immer. So, Fotos. Gucken, wie's jetzt
abkackt. By the way, wenn Nextcloud langsam sein sollte, kann man auch noch ne Redis-Cache
dran... exellent. Also, ich, ich, ich würde davon ausgehen, dass ich das als ein User
oder maximal zwei User-Instanz nicht brauche. Oh, funktioniert. Also, bis jetzt. Oh, oh,
na gut, da kackt der Browser ab, wenn die das nicht richtig gemacht haben und das oben
nicht wieder raus werfen. Schauen wir mal. Schauen wir mal. Ohje. SmallKS. Ähm, übrigens,
also, wenn, ja, die Default-Einstellung ist, dass das alles... okay, okay, oh, oh, fuck,
das spackt schon übelst rum. Äh, wenn der die Default-Settings ist, dass der meine kompletten
Bilder und komplette Fotos durchsucht, ich weiß, es ist unpopulär heutzutage, aber wie
wär's mit, mit Pages? Weil so muss man ja komplett alles laden, wenn ich zu einem alten
Foto will. Das ist doch, äh, total hängen geblieben, mal ehrlich. Endloscroll ist in
den meisten Fällen echt mehr Fluch als Segen. Also, überlegt euch mal, ich will jetzt,
ich will mir jetzt die Fotos anzeigen lassen, die, äh, schon drinnen waren. Kannst vergessen.
Dafür gibt's doch die Suche, ja doch, die Suche an der Stelle funktioniert, also, die
Suche ist übrigens weg. Wo ist die Suche hin? Frog. Das finde da, ja. Dener Teilnamen finde
da. By the way, das mit Endloscroll finde ich auch fail. Warum kann ich hier nicht einfach
sagen, ich will nach unten oder Pages? Ich finde, gerade für Dateiverwaltung ist Pages
eine viel nettere Geschichte, gerade mit Ordnern, wo viel drinnen ist. Das ist ganz, das ist
ganz schön am Rumspacken gerade. Okay, aber die Fotos App ist mit tausend Bildern schon
am Ende. Kann man, man kann den Kram ja noch nicht mal sortieren, es gibt ja noch nicht
mal einen Knopf, es gibt ja noch nicht mal einen Knopf, sort by, sort by älteste, neueste,
sonst was, oder sehe ich das falsch? Das ist alles so halbherzig, ich weiß nicht, das ist
so, anstatt irgendwie eine neue Talk App einzubauen und einen kann man baut und einen neuen Mail
klein und sonst was, könnte man sich vielleicht mal drauf konzentrieren, zumindest die Basic
Features einzubauen. Ja, ich könnte den Pull-Request stellen, aber ich will keinen Pull-Request
stellen, ich kann aber als User das trotzdem haben wollen. Ja, das ist so, das ist so wie
wenn man sagt hier, nur wenn du es nicht selbst eine bessere Idee hast, darfst du was kritisieren,
das ergibt ja auch keinen Sinn. Es gibt viele Bereiche, die mich im täglichen Leben betreffen,
von denen ich persönlich nicht genug Ahnung habe, dass ich es vielleicht besser machen
könnte, aber die mir trotzdem auf den Kicks gehen. Zum Beispiel, dass die Bahn so oft
zu spät kommt, geht mir auf den Sack. Ich habe intern von der Bahn viel zu wenig Ahnung,
als dass ich einen sinnvollen Vorschlag machen könnte, wie die Bahn das besser machen könnte,
keine Ahnung, aber es geht mir trotzdem auf den Kicks. So, probieren wir mal ganz hart
drauf, machen wir 5.000. Ok, Bash Expand ist gut, ja ja. Muss Limits bisschen hoch stellen.
Machen wir halt so, bis wie viel darf ich denn? Darf ich bis 3.000? Nein. Habe ich Limits
zu niedrig. Jetzt doch eine Schleife, ha? So, mal gucken. Zeigt mir eine Desktop App,
die mit 1.000 Vorschaubildern funktioniert. Kein Problem. Ich habe nicht so viele Fotos,
aber da müsste ich, keine Ahnung, eine Viertelstunde suchen hätte ich eine. Das ist wahrscheinlich
überhaupt kein Ding. Also, eine Desktop App mit 5.000 Vorschaubildern. Ist ja nicht so,
als Vorschaubilder jetzt irgendwie großartig was verursachen würden. Und das Problem sind
gar nicht die Vorschaubilder. Die Vorschaubilder funktionieren ja sogar ziemlich gut. Das Problem
ist, dass du hier nicht mehr richtig hinzurecht findest. Du kannst es weder sortieren nach
Zeit noch nach Hinzufügendatum, noch nach Name. Das ist doof. Klar, man kann über den
Filebrowser gehen. Und übrigens ist es gerade voller Abkacken. Wahrscheinlich kann das sogar
Windows Fotos. Und Windows Fotos ist mega der Sack, ja. Ey, man, sogar, wahrscheinlich
kann es sogar der Windows Explorer, ja. Wahrscheinlich kann es, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Wahrscheinlich kann es sogar der Windows Explorer. Das probieren wir jetzt echt mal aus, ob der
Windows Explorer kann. Äh, haben wir noch Links drauf hier? Wahrscheinlich kann es sogar
der Windows Explorer. Bin ich muted? Du bist muted. Oma. Äh, Bilder-Test. Das Einzige,
wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, was jetzt richtig rumspacken wird, ist der Windows Virenscanner.
Chat. Chat. Ich hab ne Vorschau laufen. Ich seh in der Vorschau weder, dass es hängt,
noch, dass der Ton weg ist. Ja, okay, probieren wir das mal aus. Aber wir haben hier Vega
drauf. Was haben wir da genommen? Ich glaub, das da, ne? Ist doch vollkommen egal. Welches
Bild haben wir da genommen? Nehmen wir einfach das Gleiche. Man konnte doch hier so schön
raustracken und droppen. Explorer, null. Erst mal Explorer aufmachen. Konnte man das hier
nicht irgendwie raustracken und droppen? Piss dich, Alter. Ah, doch, mit VmW Tools ging
das. Exzellent. So. Ah, das konnte man doch gar nicht. Ne, Exe muss man angeben, dass
das funktioniert hat. So, jetzt kopieren wir nämlich den Kram. Mal da rein. 1KS. Bildertest.
So. Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das mit dem popelten
Winners Explorer aussieht, ob der das kann. So, 0-1000..jpg. Ah, lul, vergess ich immer
wieder. Wer weiß, was der jetzt versucht herauszuführen. Ah, ich hab, ich bin ein Kacknoob. Außerdem
hab ich ne komische Bell noch an. Ich muss doppelt Punkt machen. Äh, doppelte Punkte
machen. So. Komm mal. Oh, der hat nicht alles kopiert. Aber sogar ein Winners Explorer kann's.
Außer dass das übelst abspakt. Oh, ich hab, der, das hat nicht richtig kopiert. Bild
ist kaputt. Wir haben auch ein KS zerstört, Leute. Pepeherz. Das, Basti, natürlich findet
man die Gründe, warum das in Nextcloud so ist. Ja. Ich sag ja auch nicht, dass das komplett
unverständlich ist, warum das in Nextcloud so ist. Aber eben hieß es noch, find ne Windows-Version,
die das kann. Sogar der fucking Winners Explorer kann's. Ich kann mir auch viele Sachen erklären,
warum Dinger so sind, deswegen müssen sie mir ja trotzdem nicht gefallen. Warum ist
der jetzt eigentlich kaputt gegangen dabei? Beim Kopieren. Ach, ich glaube, kann das sein,
dass das ursprüngliche Bild schon kaputt ist? Ist das ursprüngliche Bild schon kaputt?
Ey, Moment mal, kannst du, wie kommt man das nochmal nach Zeit umstellen? Date. Das ursprüngliche
Bild ist MonkaS 9. Oh, das ursprüngliche Bild ist schon kaputt. Also, also hat er alles
richtig kopiert und es funktioniert einfach. Ach, ich hab's überschrieben. Ich hab's während
dem Kopieren überschrieben. Stimmt. Ja klar, natürlich. Ich hab's während dem Kopieren
überschrieben. Klar. Eigentlich logisch, ne? So, MonkaS. Copy Paste. Hier rein. Replace.
So, da war er. Hier. MonkaS 1 war das jetzt. Oder? Ist das so? Das nenne ich jetzt jetzt
was ganz anderes. Omega Lull. Ich kann es nämlich auch nicht überschreiben. Ah, da
sind wir. Guck mal, sogar der Windows Explorer kriegt das ohne Probleme hin. Mal gucken, ob
ich hier gleich 5000 machen darf. Ah, darf ich nicht. Weiß nicht, was Standard Limits
sind. 1000, ne? Und ich mein, wenn sogar der Windows Explorer das hinkriegt, dann ist das
durchaus machbar. Ja, aber wie dem auch sei, da ging es ja gar nicht so sehr drum. Teste
mal die Winno- Oh, ne, ne. Das Ding ist wahrscheinlich kompletter. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo mache
ich denn die Windows Foto App überhaupt aus? Auf, hier, Fotos. Was? No. Turn off people
settings. Yes. Okay. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Kram überhaupt funktioniert. Leute,
wie bedient man das? Ich hab den Kram noch nie verwendet. Albums. Ne. Ich hab keinen
Ahnung, wie man das verwendet. Ich hab legit keine Ahnung. DKZama, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Subscription, Big Brain. Okay, okay, okay. Wie könnte das funktionieren? New Album.
Wie geht das? Wie ver- Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommen die Windows Big Brain Bedienkonzepte.
Import. From a Folder. Ne, ich will ein neues Album. Neues Album. Neues Album heißt CAC-W.
Ne. Ich will ein neues Album erstellen. Create. Achso. Ah. Import from- Ach, jetzt verstehe
ich das. Äh, okay, vielleicht. Das war keine so gute Idee. Import. Import. Oh, das mag
der wahrscheinlich nicht. Doch, hier. Oh, oh, jetzt. Guck die Foto App. No items to match
here such. Add this folder. Und nu? Da sind sie. Kann diese komische Such- kann diese Suche
sich mal verdrücken hier? Was ist ein CAC-App? Was ist ein Crap-App, Alter? Würde ich im
Leben nicht verwenden, ne? Das checkt man die RAM-Auslastung. Ah, das sind die VMs. Leute,
das sind die VMs. Das sind die VMs. Die VMs belegen ordentlich. Äh, und jetzt? Kann
ich jetzt create? Ach nee, select all. Create. Oh, Leute, es sieht uns. Es sieht uns. Hab
Angst. Jawoll. Perfektes Video. Perfektes. By the way, warum ist das so laut?
Perfekte Video Slideshow. Besser geht's nicht. Remix it for me. Jawoll. Ich mach, ich mach,
ich mach sogar mal den Nintendo-Sound aus, dass man hier die pure Windows-Experience genießen
können. Oh, Album. Das ist ja toll. Dieses Feature, das brauch ich unbedingt auch in Next
World. Und gibt's da nicht ein Album? Kann man da vielleicht den Titel noch ändern?
Edit a copy, was passiert denn dann? Immer ganz ehrlich, mir war bis jetzt gar nicht
klar, dass die Windows-Foto-App sowas kann. Und ich frage mich gerade, warum kann die
sowas? Braucht das jemand? Ja, du kannst den Titel, stimmt, wo kann man den Titel ändern?
Title. Edit. Text. Die haben sich richtig Mühe gegeben. Das ist so ein Movie Maker
für ein Video Slide. Sieht auch genauso hässlich aus. Und wie kann ich hier Album ändern? Hier
oben kann man das ändern. Album 2. Wird da noch Album 2 draus? Nein. Wie kann man denn
hier jetzt? Ah. Album. Cute. Chat. Aja ja. Adventure. Perfekt. Jetzt haben wir die beste
Slideshow aller Zeiten. Background Music. Happy Beat. Ah, mehr gibt's nicht. Sync your
Video to Music. Ok. Da seh ich einen Unterschied. Ja, doch. Die Bilder switchen zum Beat. Sowas
Geiles. Ganz toll. Windows. Ganz, ganz toll. So. Ich lösche den Kram mal wieder. So.
Machen wir mal weg. Ich hätt's mit RM löschen sollen. Wie krieg ich denn jetzt die importierten
Fotos wieder weg? Sonst hab ich irgendwie 300 oder 500 MP komplett wasted. High Speed
Windows File Deletion. Ich würd sagen, damit mach ich mein nächstes YouTube Video. Ja.
Was schreibt mir einer ein Skript, was ne Windows vor allem erstellt, mit zuverlegenden
Online Accounts und dann Millionen von Memes automatisch auf den MSR verlegt und im Anschluss
neuer VM... Alles klar. Windows irgendwie glaube ich, dass die Anzeige nicht stimmt.
Mal gucken, ob es am Ende wenigstens Null ist. Oh, immerhin, immerhin. Es ist am Ende
Null. Bin ich froh, dass der Account keine Admin-Rechte hat, weil wahrscheinlich hätte
er sonst die halbe Festplatte mitgelöscht. Oh, das ist kritische Operation jetzt. Kritisch.
Kritischer Hase. Pains-Champ. Er ist fertig. Wahnsinn. Und was sagt meine Festplatte? Moment,
auf meiner Festplatte ist jetzt mehr Platz als vorher. Wie geht denn sowas? Vorher hatte
ich nur noch 48, irgendwas. Hat der was mitgelöscht, was er nicht mitlöschen sollte?
Man weiß es nicht. Ich hoffe es ist doch alles da. Na gut, also hängen wir uns zwar nicht
weiter an der Foto-App auf, drücken wir es mal ein bisschen diplomatischer auf und sagen,
ich sehe da noch Optimierungspotential in der App. Verbesserungspotential sehe ich
da noch in der App. So, was gibt es denn sonst noch zu gucken? Also das Only Office Zeug
hat eh nicht funktioniert. Stimmt, ich wollte gucken, wie es mit Thunderbird mittlerweile
funktioniert. Ich verwende Thunderbird nur für Kalender und Kontakte, allerdings ändert
sich an meinen Kontakten nichts. Und sehr selten was. Und Kalender benutze ich so gut
wie auch nicht. Der ist halt einfach nur da eingerichtet, aber ich hab schon ewig, eigentlich
verwende ich den gar nicht. Aber ich kann euch bei der Gelegenheit mal zeigen, wie ich
das aktuell mit Notizen mache. Weil das ist meine Software, nachdem ich mich jetzt ja
den halben Abend drüber aufgeregt habe, wie nervig ich Nextcloud finde, kann ich euch
mal was zeigen, was ich gut finde. Und zwar hier mein Notizprogramm, was man irgendwie
schon installiert hat. Ich update das mal, dass wir auch die letzte Version uns angucken.
Ja, mach mal, update. Let's go. Das wollen wir nicht sehen. Positive Sachen ist nicht
gewünscht. Moment, warum update? Achso. Weil es Updates gibt. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht,
dass der updater Troublet aber machte anscheinend nicht. Was ist das für eine Version? 1.0.2.1.8.
Mal gucken, ob wir da aktuell sind. 1.0.2.3.1. Nein. Wir sind überhaupt nicht aktuell. Oh,
wo wo wo wo wo, what the. What the fuck? MonkaS? Was hat der denn für Schmerzen hier? Woops.
Ähm. Moment. Ich habe das angeblich gar nicht installiert. Worüber habe ich das denn installiert?
sag bloß snap app image ok ich habe es installiert aber ich habe es auch gleichermaßen nicht
installiert das ist sehr merkwürdig ich habe es wohl mal installiert also ergeblich habe ich das
da installiert aber ich habe es auch wiederum nicht installiert dann ist ja die einfache logische
variante ist neu zu installieren es gibt ja das ist ja fast schon windows feeling schrödingers job
den ja das ist man scharoll hier können wir jetzt mal linux in aktionen wobei es ist ja damit
linux wenig zu tun qualitative paketquellen genießen ja ist ja nicht so als wäre das
unterlinux alles besser oder du hast das app im image woanders runter geladen ne habe ich
nicht weil ich habe sie im paketmanager installiert also was der mir glaube ich sagen will ist dass
der haschwert nicht stimmt von dem was er runter lädt und das könnte daran liegen dass ich kein
clean build gemacht habe wir machen man clean bild ob es dann funktioniert meinungen zu z top
eine der besten sprachen die es gibt jeder mag nicht da hat kein bock an was genau störst du
dich da jetzt hier gerade ist ist ja was ich mache das jetzt nicht bei the way es sieht zwar so aus
ich macht es jetzt nicht weil das nicht funktioniert sondern ich rieb gute weil
wir vorher körner update gemacht haben meinungen zu z plus plus nein heute nicht heute nicht
heute nicht aber z ist eines der besten sprachen die es gibt
ok ich glaube die haben dies noch nicht aktualisiert da lädt ein anderes paket
runter als er erwartet ja ich vermute mal dass er mir sagen möchte oder was immer er mir sagen
möchte ich habe ehrlich gesagt kein schimmer kann ich das normale installieren geht das da geht
das normale zu installieren ich muss nord ins ne ne ne ok ist ja was ich lade mir mal
das offizielle app image runde wir machen die wir machen die windows wir machen die
windows taktik wir machen die windows taktik wir laden uns den kram runter releases und
wo ist es denn ist blöd und wo ist der releases button
rechts
das haben die das ist neu na
das wäre nice wenn man den joplin zeichen da gebe ich dir recht und sie müssten es gar
nicht mal selbst machen weil sie sind schon eine elektron anwendung sie könnten einfach
trauer auch einbinden das fände ich wirklich cooles feature noch wenn die wenn die trauer
auch einbinden würden das wäre wirklich cool ja
das andere nicht oder oder zumindest nicht zu meiner zufriedenheit nicht kann man ja
nicht sagen sag mal what the fuck ok hier können wir bestaunen wenn es unter mancharo
nicht funktioniert warum startet das nicht also es startet ja wohl aber es startet auch
doch nicht also je nachdem wie man es sieht es startet ohne dass man es sieht vielleicht
muss man einfach nur warten ja ich warte mal kurz ob es noch startet erstmal zwei stunden
ja das sind halt so die typischen linox sachen wenn es nicht funktioniert was ich jetzt als
nächstes probieren würde ich würde den nuke move machen und noch mal aus dem paket install aus
paketquelle installieren ok das app image startet nicht das schon mal fail das ist was
unter windows würde das definitiv sofort starten das problem ist warum ich das warum ich das
nicht machen möchte aus paketquelle installieren das dauert so ewig der kompiliert den kram
jetzt selbst also kompilieren ist zu viel gesagt der macht da note package draus also installiert
es noch gs und das ganze gedöns um daraus dann die app zu bauen das dauert ewig guckt
euch an das trauerspiel jetzt lädt er erstmal das halbe internet drunter weil jedes mal
wenn du npm package bauen willst musst du das halbe internet installieren sonst funktioniert
es nicht ja komm was juckt mich 12 sicherheitslücken in 5000 javascript paketen
da warst du der unterschied ist das startet ja noch nicht mal wenn es läuft ist die funktion
top ja npm ja der paket manager verwendet allerdings nur npm anscheinend weil ja dann
habe ich installiert äh moment warum hat er da jetzt was erstellt will mein home verzeichnen
sich hier anlocken guck mal jetzt brauche 3 stunden dafür ich mein wir können es doch
einfach unter windows installieren gucken ob es da funktioniert direkt kann man das
eigentlich downloaden aus dem shop get it on linux windows get it on windows or get a portable
version probieren wir mal aus weget und erstmal schön in bash reinpipen genauso wie man es
macht ich weiß dass das im hour gibt und ich weiß
nicht ob man our our ausspricht hat aber was mit dem bauer auf youtube zu tun irgendwie
klingt das ähnlich so portable starten da ist es wunderbar siehst du das ist der vorteil
unter windows manchmal funktioniert es einfach und hier muss er sich erstmal 3 stunden selbst
den kram bauen so erst erstmal ganz wichtig das allerwichtigste was man machen muss erst
erstmal appearance dark theme so erst dann kann man weitermachen ohne gehts schon mal
gar nicht so jetzt muss ich mal die ip raussuchen vor meinem nextcloud ding hackfont habe ich
glaube nicht installiert unter windows ne hab ich nicht unter windows installiert so
zumindest danach muss man seine nextcloud installation hier irgendwo angeben 8080 attp username max
password keck 0w apply check status achso ah webdopfuhl moment moment meine webdopfuhl
ah ich hab neugestartet ne ist es nicht rib ich hab neugestartet deswegen ist weg ja klar
müsste gleich wieder da sein gutes password ja beste meistens nehme ich ja 123456 aber
durfte ich nicht nehme ich ja jetzt so settings webdopfuhl da check ach log lost lull jetzt
jetzt brauche ich die ip von vorhin da so pass mal auf jetzt was what the fuck nooo
das ist weil ich das ding standardmäßig auf localhost hab stehen lassen jetzt ist
nur zugriff über die domain localhost erlaubt
es ist ja guck mal es ist ja unter linux mittlerweile auch installiert kann man es gleich copy pasten
und hier wieder zumachen jawoll zack man kann es übrigens in die config eintragen das
ist kein ding also ich hab hier irgendwo next docker nextcloud what ich hab doch das nextcloud
unterzeichnis gemapt wo hat er das denn hingemapt jetzt wo hat er das hingemapt ich war doch
im richtigen ordner drin so jetzt zipp mal endlich dein package genau man muss in irgendeine
config php das eintragen was meinste man kann sich aber doch in docker irgendwie anzeigen
lassen wo was gemounted ist
ne aber da ist es tatsächlich warum hat er doch inspekt genau oder auch nicht ok ne anscheinend
ist da nix gemapt großartig weil ich das doch hier angegeben habe oder ich das so machen
müssen da stand doch habe ich drüber gescrollt ja da war es war ww html aber nicht wo es
auf dem host liegt aber nicht was auf post liegt oder
war warum auch immer verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau weil man ich hab sie extra hier drin
gestartet mit dem ordner aber gut was hätte ich denn anders machen müssen jetzt das so
machen müssen eigentlich nicht ja das ist wo es liegt aber ich frag mich ehrlich gesagt
ja warum das nicht funktioniert hat
entweder ich hätte ich so machen müssen oder ach so ja das wird es natürlich erklären
wenn ich so mache dass das hätte wahrscheinlich funktioniert exzellent alles klar so jetzt
ist der kram installiert jetzt darf ich es ausführen jetzt jetzt
wtf warum startet das nicht das ist broken da ist es doch moment das lief die ganze zeit
das lief die ganze zeit nur irgendwie wird das in meiner leiste oben nicht angezeigt
kann das kann das sein das hat keinen bock auf den tray eiken das war absicht ich wollte
nicht dass ich habe es auskommentiert dass es nicht ausführt und dann ist mir aufgefallen
dass ich aus irgendwelchen gründen auskommentieren ihn nicht eingeschaltet hat was auch immer
zumindest hat es nicht ausgeführt das ding mag kein tray eiken mehr das tray eiken ist
verbugt gut aber wir können jetzt noch options sync nextcloud jetzt können wir den kram
endlich einfügen username max check status jetzt weiß ich nicht was er verschmerzen hat
ach moment das ist nextcloud das ist was anderes das hier muss ich drücken alles klar passt
jetzt zünkt er wobei er nicht files nehmen soll sondern wir machen einen eigenen notes
ordner weil das soll er nicht alle files zünken sondern notes ordner zünken ok jetzt
passt jetzt können wir zünken notes gibt es jetzt zweimal einmal klein einmal groß
nicht nicht mit nicht mit nicht unter windows dann richtig also doch unter windows schon
aber warum funktioniert das überhaupt unter windows funktioniert da nicht oder aber wir
sind ja zum glück nicht unter windows ob das jetzt gesyncht hat oder ob das jetzt noch
mehr rumspackt vielleicht sollten wir den ordner doch anders nennen falls der ja wir
sollten wir sollten das mal doch anders nennen ich warte ich warte mal bis der fertig
zünken ist sonst kackt er wahrscheinlich voll ab
jedermann sagt ich verstehe dass windows kacke ist nö ganz ehrlich für das was es machen
soll macht es windows ganz gut was ich nicht verstehe ist unter windows dass die permanenz
auch sachen anfangen und während sie noch dabei sind es umzusetzen wieder was neues
man das das macht aber microsoft gerne und und was ich auch bescheuert finde ist dass
ich seit 15 jahren oder so nicht auf die reihe bekommen ordentlichen support für desktop
anwendungen bereitzustellen weil nach wpf kam ja nichts mehr im endeffekt die haben
dann sich total verrannt mit javascript kacheln und danach mit uwp geschiss wo du bis heute
nicht ordentlich anwendung drin programmieren kannst gar nicht durch das gui zeug sondern
weil es entweder total restriktiv ist oder voraussetzungen braucht die du als nulla 15
ich baumeine app daheim entwickler nicht hast und jetzt langsam aber sicher fangen sie
ja hiermit an mit winui für unpacked geschichten wieder seit 15 jahren ein ordentliches ein
ordentliches jui framework bereitzustellen was man auch verwenden kann ok hier ist alles
gesüngt sofort so ok schmeißen wir den kram mal weg und gucken ob das die liten auch sind
wenn du es sehen habt hat man eine festparte gegriff sagt der jählermann oder schlecht
so zumindest warum ich das programm mag ist folgendes erstens gibt es das für mac äh
schwachsinn ja für mac auch für ios android mac linux windows ja es ist halt ein elektronen
programm aber gut was willst du machen ähm und was mir am besten gefällt ist folgendes
so was mir am besten gefällt ist folgendes äh was weiß ich blub vollkommen egal man
kann sowohl to do's erstellen als auch notes erstellen und für die to do's unterstützt
es also die notifications auf allen plattformen also ich kann zum beispiel sagen kein neues
to do öh öh twitch chat button so und das setze ich jetzt auf öhm moment mach mal das
im desktop noch mal wacke es äh moment moment bin ich jetzt blöd wo setze man das mit der
notification jetzt noch mal ach hier so jetzt suchst du den alarm raus also die notification
heute 21 uhr 21 uhr wird der twitch chat gebannt das ist noch eineinhalb minuten zeit und jetzt
zünden wir das mal so und ähm dann ploppt jetzt ich hoffe ich hab das jetzt eingestellt
dann ploppt jetzt in einer minute eine notification auf das funktioniert jetzt einfach man muss
dazu nix einschalten glaube aber das ging standardmäßig mittlerweile ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich dafür zumachen muss wir probieren es jetzt einfach mal aus ob in einer minute
was aufploppt zumindest das gute daran ist dass das native notifikt oder nahezu native
notifications auf allen plattformen macht also sprich wenn ich das unter windows verwende
und gesüngt hätte würde es aufploppen das heißt ich kann to do setzen mit zeit und das
funktioniert cross platform auf allen unterstützten betriebssystem was halt nahezu alles ist so
das finde ich natürlich sehr praktisch das ist eigentlich das hauptsächliche feature
warum ich das verwende also wenn um 21 uhr müsst ihr unter meine linux notification leist
ist irgendwie gerade ein bisschen kaputt ich weiß nicht warum müsst ihr hier gleich was
aufploppen irgendwo oder auch nicht und dann muss ich euch bannen alle aber ihr habt glück
es ploppt nix auf ja ihr habt glück es geht nicht ich glaube weil die notification leistung
kaputt ist wie auch immer normalerweise ploppt dann unter allen unterstützten betriebssystem
eine notification auf achtung twitch chat bannen ist jetzt ange- by the way warum kann ich
denn hier keine neue zeit setzen ok weil wir das mal reschedulen 21 uhr 2 falls die zeitzone
überhaupt stimmt aber man versteht es glaube ich und nebenbei kann der ganze kann das ganze
ding auch noch notes mit markdown support und so wie ich es am liebsten hab mit also
die vorschau braucht man nicht die vorschau kann man ausschalten irgendwo weil die markdown
vorschau finde ich komplett komplett useless wenn ich die knob dafür findet ehrlich gesagt
hier oben war das nahe und so wie ich es mache einfach markdown mit syntax highlighting das
ist mir persönlich am liebsten markdown mit syntax highlighting das ist im prinzip plaintext
mit plaintext so was es nicht gut kann sind glaube ich codeblocks da spackt es ein bisschen
rum codeblocks funktionieren nicht immer manchmal wenn man glück hat oder ich glaube die codeblocks
muss man anders machen hierfür oder muss man codeblocks einschalten wie auch immer
das verwende ich seit ein paar jahre nicht also seit eineinhalb jahren als notiz und
to do programm was irgendwie gerade mit notifications nicht funktioniert was auch immer genau und
der klipper ist auch enorm praktisch der klipper ist wirklich super praktisch kann ich auch
gerade mal zeige der web klipper der ist auch extrem praktisch ich installiere den web klipper
mal umgibt den web klipper zweimal und bin ich überhaupt im chrome ah ne ich bin ja gar
nicht im chrome lull ok chrome ja please der klipper den klipper habe ich auch der ist
der ist auch enorm praktisch so da kam jetzt dem licht gehen wir auf irgendeine webseite
gehen wir mal hier reddit selfhosted oder so irgendwo hin so erstmal anmelden ne ich glaube
er musste sich gar nicht anmelden dann macht der sync das eben mit der app selbst so und
da kann man sich jetzt auswählen wie man das ganze hinzufügen will also mal clip complete
page ach den web klipper muss man erst aktivieren moment web klipper so wenn wir es richtig
machen dann funktioniert es auch so complete clip complete page da da da confirm gibt es
verschiedene varianten und zack hat man die webseite hier drin gut jetzt halt im nur mit
text das braucht man nicht oder man sagt man kann screenshot machen man kann die url
klippen man kann die selection klippen zu seinem notizbock hinzufügen oder man kann
jetzt neu wohl auch komplett mit html das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert ich war meistens
das da und schon hat man die seite ok ich muss die vorschau anmachen schon hat man sich
die vorschau geklippt so ein bisschen so ein bisschen wie wie das da hat man so ein bisschen
wie ein eigenes archiv ich finde es ganz praktisch nicht nicht in der art und weise wie ich es
wie ich es hier gemacht habe sondern zum beispiel wenn ich sage ach guck mal genau das brauche
ich dann sagste clip selection und später kannst du es dann bei dir einfügen dass du
ach ja genau das wollte ich ja hier in mein notiz in mein notizbock einfügen das ganze
also web klipper ist sehr praktisch ap token liegt o m f g so ja das ist der web klipper
copy token ja es ist eh von es ist eh von außen nicht zugänglich bei mir wie heißt
das notizprogramm joplin das verwende ich schon seit einer ganzen weile und auch wenn
jetzt irgendwie meine notizen also meine meine pop ups für notifications nicht funktionieren
und ich ehrlich gesagt nicht weiß warum ich habe keine keine ahnung vielleicht habe ich
ausgeschaltet also normalerweise macht das notification dass jetzt das to do ansteht im
in oh nein es ist disabeled das ist wenn man darauf zugreifen will also das geht ja von
außen ähnlich schau trey icon apply ja ne das trey icon scheint broken zu sein genau
es hat genau das kann auch verschlüsseln standardmäßig wenn man möchte dass das zum
beispiel wenn man seinen notizen auf dropbox oder so speichert dass man es direkt verschlüsselt
ablegt es kann übrigens auch emojis aller wichtigste ohne ohne emojis geht ja gar nichts
mehr heutzutage so und wenn einem die schrift hier zu klein ist man kann das man kann das
anpassen also sprich man kann hier auch kann die editor font size ändern immer davon aus
man kann auch irgendwo die font size vom frontend ändern ja warum die notifications gerade rum
spacken verstehe ich nicht aber irgendwie ist das gerade ein bisschen broken welche
sync option du kannst auch fast alles sunken du kannst dropbox sunken one drive sunken
oder in xx beliebiger web daf oder direkt nextcloud oder aufs filesystem spätestens aufs filesystem
geht es mit jedem sync den es gibt dann gehst du beispielsweise in den ordner wenn du jetzt
irgendwie was gibt es noch wenn du neben dropbox one drive jetzt noch jahu drive oder so verwendest
was auch immer das ist ob es das überhaupt gibt dann wird sie den fad angeben von einem
jahu drive ordner der gesynced wird und dann wird das auch funktioniert kannst das mit
nahezu allem sunken ja das mein to do allerdings nicht das steht sehr gerne drin ist auch blödsinn
ist ja ein eigenes dass das nicht keine notifications geschickt hat finde ich merkwürdig aber ich
habe ihnen ein bisschen kaputt weil das hat auch kein kein icon und sowas ich versuche
noch mal das app image zu installieren was ist org es gibt ich glaube es vergeht keine
woche mit javascript programm wo nicht irgendwas neues rauskommt ob das geht das heißt ja
anders darf ich doch mal das ganze mal ab im app image installieren habe es doch hier
aber das icon ist kaputt das ist fail dass das icon kaputt ist application normalerweise
geht das icon weil ich habe sie in meiner in meiner normalen täglichen linux kiste
auch und da ist das tray icon da ich weiß nicht warum das tray icon hier nicht geht
dann hätte man in meiner zeit ja auch ein tray icon ich vermute mal das ist einfach
gerade kaputt und mit der tray integration sind anscheinend auch die notifications kaputt
was ziemlich doof ist weil normalerweise würde hier oben die notification aufbloppen hallo
dein to do steht an gucken wir mal github tray icon no tray icon ooooh tray icon kaputt
ne openbox haben wir nicht tray icon ist kaputt ja das ist fail na
also ah guck mal tray icon disappear ich bin anscheinend nicht der einzige
aber wie gesagt das ist mal um was positives zu sagen das ist ein programm was ich echt
empfehlen kann das ist top für mich das praktischste notes programm eben weil es to do's und notes
in einem ist inklusive notifications auf allen plattformen probiert grad noch mal was aus
wenn man docker stopp nex cloud hab ich nicht nex cloud genannt ne wär ja auch langweilig
wenn ich dem ding ordentlichen namen gegeben hätte wir starten das ganze noch mal und
jetzt versuche ich mal den richtigen ordner anzugeben dass ich da auch dass ich da auch
zugreifen kann drauf ja so jetzt aber äh wie hat man dem ding noch mal name gegeben docker
kommando zeile dass das ding ordentlichen namen kriegt minus minus name das wär zu
einfach minus minus da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt was ich glaube es war sonst minus n
übrigens ist es nicht ich darf es nicht home docker es ist home max docker was jetzt aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht wie ging das dann noch mal gift docker container name das
war total simpel man musste das man musste das ansonsten immer überschreiben noch mit
dass das danach löschen soll und sowas auto name rename docker containers alles klar minus
doch minus minus name vielleicht muss man das vorne machen spackt ja manchmal rum minus
minus name next einfach mal nur next ah hier das andere gab es schon ok das heißt ich
gehe jetzt mal wieder auf log raus jetzt müsste es ja leer sein wieder ist ein log genau jetzt
ist es leer ok admin passwort 123456 noch mal nein die recommended apps installieren
wir jetzt erstmal nicht da sind wir und jetzt kann man hier kann man hier domains eintragen
in den settings ne das wär zu einfach ne das wär zu einfach next cloud add domain da muss
ich bestimmt echt how to add trusted domain da muss ich wirklich in die config datai na
gut meinetwegen wenn ich so als hände ich was gegen config files ja da guck da ist alles
drinne config da müssen wir es erstmal stoppen docker stopp next so config ne ne ne config
config auf ja alles gut weil so trusted domains das da localhost muss man das so machen ich
meine das ist php ein schimmer von php aber ich glaube so sieht das dann warum muss man
bei warum muss man bei einem php array den index davor schreiben sollte es nicht klar
sein dass das null ist und dass das eins oder ist es gar kein array im eigentlichen sinne
sondern es ist eher so eine addictionary was array heißt dass das der key ist und das
ist der value ich hab keinen plan von php brauche man da ein paar abschließendes komma
auch nicht so und jetzt müsste ich ja von meinem anderen rechner drauf zugreifen können
wenn das alles funktioniert ach ist das so ok 80 80 aha brö dark reader geh fort
nein nein ja never add new folder notes zack und jetzt starte ich noch mal unter windows
und ich gucke mal ob unter windows ob die irgendwie die notifications kaputt gemacht
haben gerade normalerweise ploppt das direkt auf normalerweise ploppt das direkt auf ohne
jegliche probleme wenn du dann noch wenn du eine to do eine zeitpunkt hinzufügst elite
so richten wir den kram noch mal ein options sync ach guck mal was hab ich gemerkt ach so
success habe ich notes hinten mit angegeben oder habe ich wieder vergessen notes anzugeben
habe ich wieder pp guard ich habe wieder pp guard massive pp gar guck jetzt habe ich hier
den ganzen anderen kram mitgesüngt ah gut wie dem auch sei wir legen jetzt noch mal
ein to do an ich will gucken ob es mich jetzt benachrichtigt new to do diesmal wird nicht
der twitch chat gebannt subs giften das heißt wir können jetzt auch das funktioniert subs
giften und zwar um 21 uhr pogo um 21 uhr 20 keck weh so jetzt zünden wir das mal
jetzt warten wir eine minute so und von der idee her sollte es jetzt halt auch ich glaube
ich sollte auf muss das auf auf linux normal starten wenn ich wenn ich schnell bin geht
das vielleicht das muss ich innerhalb von einer minute schaffen options sync admin admin
123456 check back so und jetzt zünden oh nee jetzt überschreibt das vielleicht mal gucken
was passiert aber so clever ist und es checkt weil es sollte eigentlich noch zünden wobei
da ein bisschen rumspackt wenn das 20 notes zu einem anderen gehören ne genau das sagt
hier irgendwas stimmt nicht unsere falls passen nicht zusammen geben wir mal options da konnte
man sagen sync failsafe raus machen so mal gucken was jetzt passiert ob jetzt was aufploppt
da ist es subs giften es hat funktioniert wie kann man random twitch gift random sub
wie geht das überhaupt wie kann man random subs giften ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht
slash gift oder so slash gift nee einfach nur so aber verschenken ok achtung leute cute
chat der chat der chat hat es verdient das ist jetzt e big brain ich bezahle jetzt geld
und die hälfte kriege ich davon wieder so wer hat was gekriegt evaded wer hat was gekriegt
das war quasi die donation an twitch richtig also im prinzip habe ich jetzt 25 euro
an twitch überwiesen von der ich dann 12 50 wieder krieg ja so und jetzt jetzt kann
ich euch eigentlich zeigen was ich was ich was ich meinte so ich kann jetzt von linux
einstellen also dass das wirklich dass es auch gut cross platform funktioniert ich kann
zu der linux einstellen 21 23 will ich den notification für dieses to do haben so und
dann sync ich das sync ich das hier rüber also das sync auch alle paar minuten mal alle
fünf minuten ist glaube ich default mäßig so und wenn das gesynced hat wird sich jetzt
ja auch gleich die zeit aktualisieren oder auch nicht normalerweise sollte ich jetzt
die zeit aktualisieren hat gut funktioniert mal gucken ob es geht hat kein bock möchte
sich möchte sich nicht updaten und es updatet auch nicht eh ja vorführeffekt lul ach der
sync noch der ist einfach nur lahm lulw dass mal dem finanzamt erklärt ich glaube da muss
man nichts erklären ich war gespannt ob jetzt die alarmzeit updated ja konkret hat die alarmzeit
geupdatet das war einfach zu schnell so und jetzt haben wir wenn man das jetzt minimieren
und im hintergrund laufen lassen also ich habe das ist ein das ist das einzige programm
was ich bewusst in auto start gemacht habe appearance nee general ja wo war das jetzt
mit den mit dem tray icon noch mal so als gammels hier im tray icon rum und um 25 kriegen
wir eine notification sowohl unter windows als auch unter linux nur unter linux ist es
gerade anscheinend kaputt warum auch immer das tray icon ist ripp gerade aber man sieht
es ich habe es unter linux angelegt es hat sich gesüngt unter auf windows und unter
windows gibt es jetzt gleich eine notification 25 und 25 windows es ist 25 subs giften keqw
und das gute daran ist es funktioniert komplett cross platform ja ich weiß anscheinend ist
es hier irgendwie brauchen seit der letzten version und das halt kostet komplett cross
platform über windows linux mac android ios komplett kostenlos open source und zünkbar
über jeden x-beliebigen dienst mit guter next cloud integration da kann man sich echt
nicht beschwerden deswegen wie gesagt eines der besten programme in der richtung finde
ich ja das ist eine der ganz wenigen sachen die ich tatsächlich mit der next cloud noch
mache im endeffekt das meiste benutze ich ja gar nicht von der next cloud deswegen sage
ich ja habe ich heute gesagt letzte chance für next cloud weil ich eben kaum anwendungszwecke
für next cloud noch habe ja so sieht es aus ja leute gibt es denn sonst noch so also auch
heute jetzt wo ich mir das angeguckt habe muss ich sagen irgendwie bin ich nicht warm
geworden mit ähm den thunderbird kalender synth muss ich jetzt nicht probieren denke
ich der wird noch funktionieren ne ich hab noch eine halbe stunde Zeit genau andy techie
finde ich auch genau den eindruck hat es auch gemacht so die ganzen graben gerade mal wieder
löschen achso stopp lull erstmal stoppen und dann löschen erstmal drei stunden beenden
ja löschen eigentlich auch mit sudo wenn es sein muss ups hallo so ähm und nun müssen
wir auch das alt das andere löschen was ist hier was hier überhaupt docker alles reingeschmissen
hat docker rm den da den da moment das stimmt überhaupt nicht so ein bisschen kleiner machen
so ne doch passt den da den da den da den da alle alle bitworn bitworn können wir auch
klein mitlöschen das werden wir eh nicht mehr verwenden den da den da so alles weg aber
images noch übrig kann man auch löschen werde ich auch nicht mehr verwenden so sehr
schön jetzt haben wir wieder ein bisschen mehr platz hat auch vorher schon genug platz
muss ja nicht unnötig zeug übrig lassen doch das gucke ich mir noch mal neu an das
gucke ich mir noch mal an das habe ich das letzte mal habe ich zu schnell oder zu ungenau
geguckt das sah für mich so aus als musst du immer über den externen sind so auf ergehen
aber die default settings sind einfach nur ein bisschen murks das geht komplett lokal
was gibt es denn da für alternativen eigentlich noch wie gesagt ich glaube bei mir wird es
drauf rauslaufen das wird eine nummer einfacher gemacht nextcloud fliegt raus ich suche mir
irgendwas raus für mega upload aber leute es wird mal wieder zeit es wird mal wieder
zeit hast du das neue nextcloud schon getestet ja gerade es wird mal wieder zeit leute aber
vorher will ich mir noch was anderes angucken bevor wir uns das jetzt geben ich wollte es
nämlich auch fertig erzählen also bei mir wird es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen verschlankt
alles ich werde mir sowas wie sing sing raussuchen für synchronisation von ein paar wichtigen
files rein bei mir lokal und je nachdem wie gut es mit dem smartphone funktioniert oder
nicht verwende ich es gar nicht auf dem smartphone aber ich verwende es eh nur so dass ich auf
dem smartphone oder von vom und auf smartphone sinke wenn es bei mir lokal im wlan ist internet
freigeben mache ich eh nicht dafür so wichtig ist es meistens nicht dass das unmittelbar
gesüngt wird und für einen kal daf kalender suche ich mir einen kal daf solver raus und
installiere den dann habe ich zwei simple sachen die für sich allein genommen die sachen
gut können und nextcloud fliegt weg so und jetzt wird es aber mal zeit hier wobei davon
bestimmt gar nicht mehr abspielen oder also ich glaube nicht dass kim dort komm ich striked
aber man weiß ja nie mega upload excellent so mehr geht nicht ich kann nur 20 sekunden
spielen oder so da kann ich immer noch rausreden mit war preview ja man kann aktuell man kann
aktuell daher auf twitch kein risiko eingehen ich glaube dass das der das der letzte ist
der da mitmachen wird bei der geschichte aber man weiß ja nie mega sending files across
the globe just mega upload die hatten keine ahnung auf was sie sich da einlassen die da
im video rumspringen alternativ.me und alternativ.to was ist da der abklatsch von was alternativ
to gibt es glaube ich schon länger aber das ist das das eine ist doch abklatsch vom anderen
mega guck mal da ja das werden wir wahrscheinlich ausprobieren pido was ist pido jump share
pido hat es was mit dem denk ich mal nicht droppler also how to start up name in einem
in einem wort droppler das ist so wirklich mehr hipster start up name geht nicht als
droppler was ist das price ok ach das kostet was nee ist umsonst für die private hab ich
noch nie gehört vorher ehrlich gesagt in github komm wieviel github sterne das hat
auch in go auch noch hipster language jetzt gehts ja los hier das ist was anderes das
andere sind pap ok ich hab nix gesagt das ist auch in pap pido core chat jetzt reißt
euch mal zusammen ah gpl war das die apache war das nicht die apache variante nee nee
apache heißt apache license was ist ei was ist ei gpl ei gpl afero das hat nichts mit
afro zu tun oder warum gibt es da schon wieder 30.000 licenzen mein dark reader nervt mich
langsam was ist der unterschied was ist der unterschied versus gpl ok wenn das bei knu
wenn da das stahlmann schon wieder am start ist dann ist das ja natürlich viel freer
komm mal das bin ich wirklich die einzige die sachen frage komm mal es gibt sogar hilfreich
antworten ok das natürlich heftig also falls du es verwenden willst also das kannst du
schon mal nirgendswo einbinden das ist schon mal ausgeschlossen
da war die gpl wahrscheinlich hat genug für den für die leute ich weiß nur dass man
sich mit lgpl relativ sicher sein kann dass man quasi alles mitmachen kann von close source
bis open source bis web services bis auf den mond schießen mit lgpl kannst du alles machen
choose a license oh das habe ich mir vor ein paar weile das kenne ich glaube ich das kenne
ich glaube ich ja genau ja das habe ich schon mal gesehen ist da auch ist da auch dings
dabei ja ist das cm ne aber wie heißt das noch mal dass das was gerne für bilder verwendet
wird ccm ne creative commons das ist da auch bei aber das content ist leistet an der creative
commons ein moment die die die seite ist leistet an der creative commons aber creative commons
selbst ich ist nicht bei den leistungen aufgelistet wobei ok den geht es ja nur um software geschichten
hier den geht es ja den geht es ja nur um software geschichten ich glaube creative commons ist
jetzt für software nicht so das ding vor software ich kann immer schreibe glaub nicht ach was
auch immer ist mir ehrlich gesagt wurscht das sollen sich irgendwelche stonks leute angucken
was will people gift er soll sich doch freuen was gar nicht wo war was war schwach bestört
ihn dass wir den leute subs giften doch nicht schlimm das klingt nach mega man oder f0
am ende macht man e stack overflow driven program ich finde auch überhaupt nichts verwerfliches
dran sich sachen von stack overflow zu kopien pasten das einzig dumme ist wenn man ohne sich
anzugucken was die dinge eigentlich machen will copy pasten wenn man irgendein problem
hat sucht danach was findet eine beschreibung eine lösung auf stack overflow copy pastet
die sich erstmal rein guckt ob alles funktioniert und passt danach für seine eigenen bedürfnisse
an ist es vollkommen ok einfach blind stack overflow copy pasten das steht ja übrigens
auch noch bei uns irgendwo im to do wir wollten ja mal versuchen irgendein kleines program
zu basteln nur aus stack overflow copy pastest hast du das nintendo liegt mitbekommen ich
habe gestern ein video geguckt ja das nie doch das video habe ich gestern geguckt ja
es ist bei nintendo ist so viel zeug geliegt vom gameboy bios bis zu mario world prototypen
und sonst was was ich beeindruckend finde das hat er glaube ich hat er im video glaube
auch gesagt dass nintendo den scheiß noch hat es gibt so viele spiele remakes die nicht
möglich waren weil das source code auf wegen der diskette am arsch der welt verrottet ist
und nintendo hat den ganzen kram noch ja der liegt das stimmt das habe ich auch gesehen
der liegt schon eine ganze weile her aber es haben sich jetzt immer immer mehr leute
da durchgekämpft und er erkennt erst lange was da was da eigentlich drinne ist hat das
hier eigentlich schon mal jemand verwendet jetzt wo ich da gerade drauf kommen hat das
schon mal jemand ausprobiert auf seine raspberry pie ist ja angeblich ein minimal debian und
ansonsten halt ein normales debian das wollte ich mir mal angucken das logo das ist halt
ein schwarzer raspberry oder so keine ahnung könnte aber auch an meinem dark reader das
logo sieht sieht monka s aus ja das stimmt das logo sieht gefährlich aus so als fällst
dich nachts an aus dem raspberry pie und übrigens letztens bin ich über eine coole
seite gestolpert auf der war ich schon öfters mal drauf ohne sie mir anzugucken das ist
eine seite wo vermute mal unterschiedliche leute ein bisschen was zu ihren raspberry
pie projekten schreiben und wo man ideen bekommen kann was man im raspberry pie so macht die
fand ich gar nicht übel ist jetzt zwar für mich jetzt direkt nichts dabei gewesen wo
ich gesagt habe ja das ist das was ich schon immer mal ausprobieren wollte aber ich finde
es nicht übel einfach mal ganz nett beschriebene raspberry pie projekte ist ja ist natürlich
viel spaß sind dabei ne ich mein moment wo war es dann das das wollte ich ja auch noch
mal machen raspberry in android auf raspberry pie ja warum ist genauso wie windows auf
raspberry pie warum geht ja mittlerweile wollte ich übrigens auch mal im stream ausprobieren
eigentlich hatte ich eigentlich hatte ich vor dass heute im stream weil ich habe ja
am wochenende gesagt montag machen wir mit raspberry pie was eigentlich hatte ich vor
heute windows zu installieren auf raspberry pie bis ich mir da mal ein tutorial durchgelesen
habe und festgestellt habe wie grottenschlecht das funktioniert du kannst beispielsweise
die netzwerkarte nicht verwenden und die usb anschlüsse vom raspberry pie nicht verwenden
du kannst die ganzen anschlüsse unter windows raspberry pie nicht verwenden so was man machen
muss ist man installiert windows über eine sd karte und dann muss man über usb c einen
usb hub dran machen also die seitlichen usb anschlüsse einen usb hub dran machen und
dort ein netzwerk adapter per usb an den usb hub das windows überhaupt netzwerk nee nee
nein nein nein nein nein nein das war nicht ich warte bis es windows dreiber für raspberry
pie gibt der eben das zeug auch unterstützt und dann machen wir das das gibt das muss
man muss ja nicht muss er nicht jeden müsst machen man kommt an das arme image von windows
ran ja es gibt ein projekt pie windows wie ist das windows on raspberry oder so vor genau
das vorproject was übrigens gerade gedidost wird oder so keck weh aber zum glücklicher
weise geht das ganze über cloudflare und die seite geht trotzdem noch das ist windows
iot core das ist windows iot core was da drauf läuft und die haben das schon fix und fertig
für einen gemacht man kann sich das hier einfach downloaden
und installieren allerdings es geht halt nichts es gehen die usb anschlüsse nicht und es
gehen die es geht der netzwerk port geht nicht das das bringt ja nix da hast ja nix von es
sei denn du machst mit einem usb hub am usb c ansonsten läuft es wohl ganz ok
nein wlan schon mal gar nicht der usb port geht nicht wenn der nicht geht geht wlan erst
recht nicht ist das denn die aktuelle windows version ja ja das ist windows 10 iot core
ich weiß grad nicht welche version das ist ja musst du musst du nachkommen das ist relativ
aktuell machen kann man damit nix ich finde es cool dass es geht ja und hier gibt es eigentlich
ganz nette ideen was man mit so ein asperry pie machen kann ist natürlich viel grau zone
dabei so ein so ein blackserver an sich ist natürlich nicht grau zone das ist vollkommen
legitim aber was die leute da streamen an inhalten ist oftmals grau zone kann natürlich hier
nicht dann näher beleuchtet werden statt einem pie für windows vielleicht dann lachbox
ich hab keine was lachbox ist aber wenn ich einen win wenn ich einen kleinen windows pc
nehme nehme ich gar kein single board computer sondern einen ganz billigen x86 wie heißen
die dinger noch mal nicht pentium silver dings ja so ein emmich dann ja irgendwie sowas
das ist auch ein board mit schon vor gelöteter cpu drauf aber wenn ich einen kleinen windows
stromsparen windows rechner mache dann mache ich das damit dann habe ich ein richtig vollwertiges
x86 weil mit windows mit dem armen windows kannst du eh nicht allzu viel anfangen man
kann auch ein nook nehmen der vorteil hiervon ist du hast volle anschlüsse du hast von
sata bis pc express alles drauf was man noch nicht hast seit wann ist denn plex an ein
online account gebunden eigentlich schon immer oder ich verwende kein plex ich hab das vor
jahren mal ausprobiert und da war es glaube ich auch schon so wie viel kostet das board
das ist das ist ein bisschen billiger als in otroid hats also moment war das der war
das der x86 ja es ist es ist ein ticken billiger aber es ist mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche
drin und dran wie an dem otroid board nur dass das otroid board was das ganz interessant
macht ist dass du zwei netzwerkanschlüsse hast und zweimal ne warte mal ne genau du
hast zweimal sata zwei netzwerkanschlüsse ram und eine m2s slot also es ist die frage
was man haben will ich habe aktuell das hier bei mir in der kiste also nicht hier im desktop
streaming rechner sondern das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen low performance das coole an
den cpus ist die am hardware encryption drin und man kann hier theoretisch auch videos
transcodeen aber das wichtige ist das hardware encryption drin ist deswegen macht es das
aktuell mit zum besten board für selbst bild nass geräte finde ich
der sebaro warum ich den den hat den den hier nicht für nass nehmen nehmen würde
ist der ist für nass an sich ziemlich gut weil du hast 2,5 g netzwerk ports das ist
schon mal cool du hast auch zwei sata ports und du hast hier unten noch ne m2 also man
könnte damit schon ein ordentliches kleines nass basteln was mir an dem board nicht gefällt
ist dass es so ein custom custom form faktor ist das ist kein kein mini atx iatex oder
sonst was das ist so ein custom faktor und das einzige gehäuse wo das reinpasst gibt
was es gibt ist das offizielle gehäuse und das ist hässlich es fuck guck dir das an
das sieht aus wie ein staubsaugerfilter was soll das sein
ernsthaft das ist eine tupperware schüssel mit einem lüfter nebendran das ist doch grausam
guck da seht ihr das ding mit den zwei festplattenunterdritter das ist wie gesagt das ist eine tiefkühldose
mit einem lüfter ne also sowas ist ja wirklich grausam da ist jedes china raspberry pi gehäuse
hübscher ich weiß ganz anderer formfaktor aber die sehen auch meistens hässlich aus
nagios das ist aber das aber massif oldschool nagios und das im juni 2020 und hier sind
emoji was der windows nicht anzeigen kann nagios es gibt wirklich leute die legit noch
neun nagios installieren ich bin begeistert für mich nagios hat für mich bei mir immer
einen platz in meinem herz auch wenn nagios nicht mehr wirklich so auf der höhe der zeit
aber ich mag nagios ähm warte mal jetzt gebe ich mir noch ein paar questions ähm was moment
war als bei cloud vm hdd encryption noch mit weiger also äh äh bei dem hier meinste ja
wobei warum soll ich wozu brauche ich ein reverse proxy wenn ich da hä also ja kann
ich machen aber reverse proxy auf einer auf einer cloud vm haben wir doch schon gemacht
in in in einem der letzten streams auch gar nicht so lange her warum nicht jeder wie er
will nagios haben wir vor zwei semestern gelernt excellent nagios ist nicht schlecht ich mag
nagios es ist nicht mehr wirklich so auf der höhe der zeit aber ich mag das mag nagios
viel zu wenig rgb dafür habe ich aber haus sehr genug rgb könntest dir das gehäuse
ausdrucken ja stimmt stimmt könnte ich machen aber mein 3d drucker will grad nicht mein
3d drucker will grad nicht weil ich habe ja einen okto pie dran an meinem 3d drucker
also das ist das bei die distribution wo du 3d druck uploaden kannst und sowas ok web
interface vielleicht mal dabei ja genau dann siehst du hier wie lang der druck noch dauert
und ganz hoch uploaden aber der raspberry pie ich glaube die sd karte ist irgendwie
verreckt und es startet immer richtig das muss ich auch mal neu machen äh andy techie
fragt grad falls ich verpasst habe aber was für ein nass nutzt du beziehungsweise welche
selbstbau komponenten also ich hatte ja lange zeit hier meine fette kiste am start die hier
ist so aber die habe ich jetzt schon seit einer ganzen weile abgelöst den da hatte
ich hier am start nicht nur für nass der hat so ziemlich alles gemacht was es bei mir
gab von heim automatisierung nass router fire alles alles das war mir allerdings ein bisschen
zu viel single point of failure weil wenn die kiste theoretisch wenn die kiste ausgegangen
wäre hätte ich mir nicht mal den roller an richtig hoch und runter machen können
deswegen habe ich jetzt umgebaut ich habe jetzt ein mikrotik router für internet zeug
und sonst was eine fritzbox für voib und so einen kleinen sowas hier für so ein klein
eineinhalb he rechner habe ich sogar noch ein paar bilder von ihr irgendwo hier wenn
ich hier vor dem desktop finde ja so ungefähr sieht das aus und da sieht man auf auf dem
haufen papiermüll stehen so ungefähr ist es das billigste das billigste 19 zoll gehäuse
was ich gefunden habe was hotspot festplatten raum hat das wirklich alle aller billigste
da kommst du so mit 250 euro hin aber es ist halt 10 g es hat eine 10 g karte die hier
mit so einem sli oder mit so einem pci express extension kabel angebunden ist aber es schafft
keine 10 gigabit das schafft also das absolut low budget ja es hat aber sehr viele usb anschlüsse
was ich für heim automatisierung gebraucht habe es schafft so wir haben es doch im stream
ausprobiert ich glaube so 500 mb die sekunde oder sowas wie heißt das gehäuse das weiß
ich nicht mehr das weiß ich nicht mehr das kann ich dir auch mir fällt es echt nicht
ein max morgen op klausuren kann ich dich kurz anrufen ein paar frage nee kannst aber
gerne ein paar fragen im chat stellen wenn du willst hatten wir da nicht 6 gigabit geschafft
ja kommt doch hin 500 mb die sekunde megabyte meine ich 6 gigabit sind ja ungefähr 500
mb die sekunde
das ist ein op op ist objekt oriented programming ja auf muni tabaku schieß los was willst du
wissen du hast ungefähr noch viertel stunde zeit auf gehts jetzt jetzt musst du auch jetzt
musst du auch ein bisschen was beisteuern hier so einfach kommt jetzt nicht davon in
welcher sprache macht ihr das ganze denn sag jetzt nicht c++ hoffentlich nicht c++ java
ja ok das geht ja aber da kann ich dir nichts zu sagen weil ich hier weil ich ich kann ich
kann java zwar lesen und ich könnte auch theoretisch java programmieren aber ich lese kein java
und ich programmiere auch kein java java ist doch ist ja aber ich mag java nicht aber
der einzige grund warum ich java nicht mag ist weil es java ist eigentlich gibt es mittlerweile
doch weil es von oracle ist ich mag oracle nicht wie findest du pyson so top nicht für
alles geeignet aber dort wo man es verwenden kann ist das echt gut ist zu recht eine der
beliebtesten sprachen aktuell aber java hat eine to upper method das ist richtig aber
einfach nur in einem punkt besser als c++ zu sein reicht nicht c++ ist halt überall
scheiße und nur weil irgendwo was anderes mal irgendwo nicht ganz so scheiße es macht
doch nicht aktuell gut er macht es nicht automatisch gut
gegeben ist an drei demenz
jetzt geht es los gegeben ist ein dreidimensionaler string array string array schreiben sie code
der die m größe der ersten dimension das was ist denn die m größe was meint er damit
okay ich habe keine ahnung was er was er wissen will
ja java hat ja auch nach 30 jahren jetzt generics gekriegt ja das da doch das davor das davor
hättest du jetzt so mitgekriegt schreiben sie code der die größe der ersten dimension
des arrays zurück liefert man kann doch man kann doch bei java garantiert irgendwie abfragen
wenn es ein dynamisches array ist oder auch wenn es kein aber wie groß das ganze da kenne
ich jetzt die java die java standard lip nicht gut genug
es gibt irgendwo garantiert eine in eine metode property was auch immer wo das drin steht
oh hier choose my name big brain x-länge
funktioniert
ein vorschleife mit counter wäre auch eine variante ja
das funktioniert
das thema ist ja da habe ich mir jetzt in java das okay da habe ich da habe ich zu
wenig ahnung von der standard java lip was da so an metoden dabei ist
das ist top
also in c sharp ist es relativ einfach da kannst du array get length verwenden und dann
sagt er dir das
was gemma ja ja
beste da gab es auch sogar ganz gutes video zu
joshi
das ist uralt
für
Ops
Whitechamp, weirdchamp
Was solls ihr angucken? Na das ja
Ich wollte jetzt gleich aufgehen
Die Source vom Board gibt es nicht auf Github
Monetabaku, da kann ich ja was zu sagen
Scheiß
Ach gut jetzt mehr oder weniger fertig
Das ist uralt
Variablen sind grundsätzlich bis Programmende verfügbar
Ja, nein, nö
Also die normalen Variablen sind nur innerhalb der Funktion verfügbar wo du sie deklariert hast
Oder halt wenn es was objektorientiertes ist, dann gibt es da noch ein paar Ausnahmen
Also lokale Variablen in der Funktion sind nur solange verfügbar wie die Funktion läuft
Also die werden am Ende automatisch weggeschmissen
Dann hast du noch irgendwelche Variablen in deiner Klasse drin
Die sind solange gültig wie die Instanz der Klasse lebt
Dann hast du noch irgendwelche globalen, Static, sonst was Geschichten
Die sind für immer gültig, das kommt ein bisschen auf die Programmiersprache an
Aber normalerweise, nee
Hey lieber Chat, kann mir einer sagen warum ich keine virtuelle Maschine starten kann?
Oh nee, da kenne ich mich nicht mit aus
Du könntest gucken, also ich weiß nicht wie gut die Windows-Fehlermeldungen sind
Warum das bei, unter Linux mit KVM oftmals nicht funktioniert ist
Weil man genau das was der Knarbear hier schreibt, weil Dings nicht eingeschaltet ist
VTD heißt das glaube ich
Nicht Secure Boot, VTD heißt glaube ich
Virtualisierungs, CPU-Virtualisierungsgedöns
Das ist Voraussetzung, dass es funktioniert
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung wie das mit HALPOP wie ist
Wenn du Docker erzählst, liegt es an der Virtualization gut
Mit Docker ist ja eh keine Virtualisierung im eigentlichen Szene
Dann habe ich keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich mit Windows nicht aus
Ja
Nächste Frage
Gleich was futtern
Ja Leute ich werde übrigens demnächst 36, ich wollte es ja auch noch mal im Stream sagen
Bei deinem NAS nutzt du dann Samba als Dienst oder wie schreibst du die Dateien auf dein NAS
Ja, ja, richtig
Backup-mäßig nein
Wobei eigentlich fast, fast, fast, fast
Also ich hatte es ja davor total übertrieben mit meiner fetten 4HE 8 Kernkiste
Mit 13TB Platten und ZFS RAID und alle möglichen
Jetzt habe ich es ganz simpel
Eine Platte drin 12TB und die wird auf eine externe Platte einfach einmal ersunken nachts
Und theoretisch wollte ich mich schon lange mal um verschlüsseltes Offside-Backup kümmern, habe es aber noch nicht gemacht
Was ist ein Designated Constructor
Oh das ist bestimmt irgendein Java Ding
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin ob es nicht was allgemeines ist
Also ich würde vermuten, da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht sicher
Ich würde vermuten, dass wenn du eine Klasse hast
Es kann sein, dass ich übelst Mist erzähle
Mit mehreren Constructors, dass der Designated Constructor entweder derjenige ist, da standardmäßig genommen wird ohne Parameter
Oder der, der ausgewählt wird, passen zu den Parametern
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung
One is the designated Constructor
Ich habe keinen Stimmer
Das scheint es auch nicht so wirklich zu geben oder, man findet so wenig dazu
Ach der, der initialisiert alle Felder der Designated Constructor, aha
Siehste, hätte ich nicht gewusst
Keine Ahnung
Stimmt, wir können auch Java dazu schreiben
Okay, keine Ahnung, ich habe keinen Stimmer
Ich habe echt keinen Stimmer
So eine Frage kann es noch stellen, weil dann gehe ich ins Bett, morgen wieder arbeiten
Ist ja leider schon wieder Wochenende im Monat rum
Woop old, aber wie
By the way, warum
Warum lädt er das hier nicht, ach weil du kein Sub bist
Ach so
Habe ich auch gerade gesagt
Nimmst du eigentlich wieder im Dezember den ganzen Monat frei, ja mache ich
Dezember bin ich den ganzen Monat da
Da gibt es wieder fast täglich Streams
Es gibt aber jetzt schon viele Streams, muss man mal sagen
Ob ich dann wieder jedes, wie jeden Tag ein Video mache, so wie ich mich kenne
Stream ich lieber jeden Tag, wie dass ich jeden Tag ein Video mache
Jetzt wieder eins, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, ja
24er Neues, Kott
Ey ich bin so gespannt, wie die das verheiraten mit
Warzone und dem neuen Call of Duty, ich persönlich tippe ja drauf
Die lassen Warzone Standalone weiterlaufen und streichen Modern Warfare aus dem Namen
Und bringen in Warzone auch Charaktere, Waffen und sonstige Sachen aus dem nächsten Call of Duty
Und vielleicht auch eine neue Map oder irgendwelche Geschichten in der Richtung
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Stream und File
Okay, das ist jetzt, das ist wahrscheinlich Java Implementierungsfrage, aber ein File ist
Das ist eine Frage, wie die das jetzt genau meinen
Also ein Stream ist eigentlich quasi eine
Eine Beidfolge aus dem, wie soll man das beschreiben
Im Stream liest man aus einem File, wie soll man das jetzt in Worte fassen alter
Also mit einem File Stream liest du den Inhalt vom File halt ein
Nicht auf einmal, sondern immer in Häppchen
Also quasi, ein Stream, ein Stream ist buffert, buffert read im Endeffekt, buffert read, buffert write
Und tja, was machen auch immer die mit File meinen, keine Ahnung
Meinen die mit File komplettes einlesen, komplett, ne, keine Ahnung
Eigentlich sind das dann, wenn du es so willst, zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe
Das ist mir irgendwie zu unpräzise gestellt
Wie gesagt, Stream ist buffert read, buffert write in ein File
Oder ins Netzwerk oder in sonst wo, was ist denn da die richtige Antwort zu
TonyTheBeat301, YouTube, excellent Subscription, Dankeschön
BigBrainSub, heute gehts wieder aufwärts
StonksIQ im Chat
Dankeschön für den Sub
Es ist glaub ich gar kein Prime, es ist quasi ein
Der Typ stellt kontextlose Fragen, okay das ist Fail
Weil das ist so ne Frage, die man ohne, äh, Moment wo war sie denn jetzt
Das kann man echt schwer beantworten, wenn man nicht weiß, in welche Richtung er das wissen möchte
Also wenn ich in C-Sharp ein File-Objekt habe, dann ist das erste Mal
Hat das nichts mit dem Inhalt zu tun, sondern ein File-Objekt ist eigentlich erst mal nur
Metadaten zu einem File, also sprich Größe, Dateiendung, Dateifahrt
Und das File-Objekt bietet auch Methoden an zum Lesen und Schreiben
Intern wird das wahrscheinlich über Streams funktionieren
Und es hat auch Methoden für Open Stream und sowas
Aber im Gegensatz zu so einem Meta-File-Objekt, was im Prinzip das File beschreibt, allerdings nicht den Inhalt
Ist das Stream zum gebufferten Lesen und Schreiben in und aus dem File da
So, also ich glaub, besser kann ich das nicht auf den Punkt bringen, keine Ahnung
Es ist aber, Kontextlos ist wirklich echt schwierig, ja
Das, äh, Vertus, was studierst du eigentlich?
Wenn ich mal fragen darf
Hoffentlich kein BWL-Stonks
Industrieversicherung, okay, das ist kein BWL-Stonks, das geht durch
Bitches
Das ist eine bescheuerte Antwort, aber irgendwie lustig
Oh Mann, wer darf die falschen Leute wieder sehen hier?
Instant RIP-Stream
Das ist so eine richtige Low-Brain-Antwort irgendwo
Aber ich find's trotzdem irgendwie lustig
Das ist so eine typische Antwort, die könnte ich mir mit so einem Interview von irgendeinem möchtigen Gangster-Hip-Hopper vorstellen
So nach dem Motto, es kommt raus, der Typ studiert halt
Und dann fragt ihn der Interviewer oder die Interviewerin und hier, keine Ahnung, äh
Irgendwie, setze generischer Hip-Hop-Name ein
Was studieren sie? Bitches
Ich studiere Bitches, das kann ich mir richtig gut als Antwort in so einem Interview vorstellen
Das wäre so richtig typische Low-Brain-Deutsche-Hip-Hop-Interview
Das wird einfach zu gut passen
Das ist aus irgendeiner Rap-Line, okay
Das passt einfach, genau so hört sich das an
Rightway habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass sich Haftbefehl ins Bein geschossen hat vor zwei Wochen
Sich selber wohlgemerkt
Ah hier wird gleich Werbung gemacht schon, ich sehe, ich sehe, ich sehe
Schamlose Selbst-Werbung
Mit einer Pistole hat er sich ins Bein geschossen selbst
Krasser offenbarer Gangster
Er kam ins Krankenhaus und hat sich rausgestellt, er hat sich selbst mit einer Pistole ins Bein geschossen aus Versehen
Wahrscheinlich unter Drogen-Einfluss
Wer weiß für was der sein Bein gehalten hat da
Und er war auch nicht in Offenbach
Er kommt ja nur aus Offenbach, er war natürlich Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel
Goethe-Straße-Louis-Vitore-Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar Fick auf Sponsor
Da kennt er sich aus
Auf die Abi
Warum wird bei byte max plus eins ein int raus, aber bei int max geht es wieder bei ganz vornlos
Oh das ist so eine Java-Implementierungsgeschichte
Das kommt ein bisschen auf die Sprache an
Also was passieren kann ist, maximales byte, also 255
255 plus eins könnte auch null sein wenn das overflowed
Das wäre auch eine Variante
Äh
Das ist Java-Implementierungsdetail, keine Ahnung
Bei int max würde ich ehrlich gesagt erwarten, dass es beim overflow negativ wird
Moment, in Java geht bei maximum int plus eins, geht bei Java wieder bei null los
Hä
Also entweder ist das ein signed int wovor ich mal ausgehe
Dann müsste das eigentlich wenn es overflowed und dann müsste es wenn schon Minus losgehen
Ähm
Gott
Ich bin verwirrt
Keine Ahnung warum das so ist
Also ich würde aber erwarten, dass es bei beiden sich ähnlich verhält
Vielleicht sind die einfach nur big brain und machen compiler-magic und machen dann ein int raus
Ich hab keinen Schimmer wie das in Java ist
Klingt als wäre er genauso schlau wie sie
Ja das vermute ich auch
Ich glaube allzu viel ist da echt nicht zu holen
Irgendwelche Einstiegstipps in Linux-Welt habe eben um und da bist du schon mal richtig
Wenn du es im Desktopbetrieb einsetzen willst würde ich dir Manjaro empfehlen
Zum starten
Und zwar, äh nicht Manjaro, vergiss es, wollte ich gar nicht sagen, Mint
Linux Mint nicht Manjaro, fängt mit M an muss Manjaro sein
Nein Linux Mint meine ich
Und zwar die XFCE oder Mate Edition
Weil Cinnamon in der VM nicht richtig funktioniert
Oder suchst du Ideen was du damit machen kannst
Es ist insofern real, dass die Musik einen genauso dummen Eindruck macht wie die Leute auch wirklich sind
Insofern mag es real sein
Aber dafür machen sie richtig krasses Business
Konto-Overflow
Du kannst doch anders rum, du musst einfach nur so viel negativ haben wie geht und dann ist es auf einmal plus
Ah es geht bei Int-Minimum weiter, ok dann ergibt es schon ein bisschen mehr Sinn
Warum natürlich der Datentyp wechselt, er gibt, das ist Java Implementierungsdetail
Das hat keine technische Grundlage
Das ist eine Java Implementierungsgeschichte
Malerweise würde ich von ausgehen, du legst einen Byte an
Das Ding ist ein Byte groß und wenn es da raus geht dann overflows halt
Geht von vorne los aber wird nicht zu einem anderen Datentyp, das ist merkwürdig
Wobei das ist glaube ich in C Sharp auch so
Wenn ich einen Byte plus einen Byte rechne
Was kommt denn da raus, das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert gerade
Ich würde fast sagen das ist in C Sharp auch so
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Mate und XFCE, das sind ein bisschen unterschiedliche Desktops
Musst du mal angucken was dir besser gefällt, Byte blub gleich 1, Byte blub gleich 255, blub 2
Ich sollte vielleicht mal auch irgendwo rein, blub plus 2, kommt da raus
Guck mal da, das habe ich mir so noch nie angeguckt
Das Ding ist schlau genug zu erkennen, weil das statisch ist
Weißt du wo das nicht funktionieren würde, wo ich mir ziemlich sicher bin
Wenn du das Byte dynamisch einlesen lässt, dann wird es glaube ich nicht funktionieren
Oder ist das so auch, dann bleibt es ein Byte oder, dann wird es auch ein Int
Oder macht das einfach alles
Ach die Standard, ok das wusste ich auch noch nicht
Byte plus Byte ist immer Int, unabhängig davon ob es zu viel wird
Man lernt nicht aus, das sind alles Implementierungssachen, die jeder Sprache ein bisschen anders sein können
Ja also der Unterschied sieht ein bisschen anders aus, Byte ist quasi ein altes Gnome, XFCE ist kein altes Gnome, sieht aber recht ähnlich aus
Ich würde XFCE nehmen, ganz ehrlich, mag das recht gern, weil das so leichtgewichtig ist
Aber nicht von der Bedienung her, auch ein bisschen oldschool
Ich würde auch XFCE nehmen
So Leute, ich gehe jetzt echt ins Bett, 22.25, wir sehen uns morgen, machts gut, bis denn, see you